une production du studio sfr sans filtre
de podcasts on parle de ce qu'on veut
que nous inviter d'autres sites jph
quand tu es avec moi de me plante cette
semaine sans filtre est encore une fois
présenté par terry un terrien un terrain
terrain c'est un bureau de comptables
soit + 25 ans qui existent mais ils
offrent leur expertise à des pme en fait
de 1 à 100 employés des petites et
moyennes entreprises qui oeuvrent dans
des domaines d'innovation que ce soit
par exemple les jeux vidéo des créateurs
web biotechnologies même nous aussi ça
nous allait les rencontrer les terriens
terriens ils sont parfois d'aller
rencontrer les gush et erythréens pis
pour nous mêmes faire un recours alors
expertise en fait
puis ça va nous faciliter la vie parce
qu'on ne s'est pas lancé dans studio sf
pour faire de la comptabilité puis
pourrait en fait gérés des trucs qu'on
n'a aucune expertise dans le domaine
puis c'est vraiment le fun parce que euh
c'est un petit bureau de comptables qui
au contraire des grandes firmes vont
prendre vraiment votre cas de façon
humaine qui vont traiter vont vous
traiter comme des personnes et non juste
des chiffres il offre un service clé en
main que ce soit pour la tenue de livres
les états financiers les rapports
d'impôts les demandes de crédit d'impôt
chez nous autres ça va nous aider
beaucoup à s'enlever un poids sur les
épaules dans notre entreprise qui est le
studio sfr puis on vous offre également
un code promo en fait je lis ici c'est
sans filtre lorsque vous allez prendre
votre rendez vous vous allez sauver 50 %
sur votre première année financière ce
qui est quand même très considérable
vous allez pouvoir prendre cet argent
leurs pelles investir ailleurs dans
votre entreprise
ce qui est l'objectif de toutes les
entreprises donc merci beaucoup à la
gamme des terriens terrain qui sont en
suspens sur important dans le monde du
podcast au québec vit on est très
reconnaissant de votre appui
sinon tu dois être cette semaine dont le
reçu alexandre champagne 1 que petite
cabane faite kiko nul que ce qu'on
connaît pour différentes raisons demi gd
connu d'abord on n'a pas dans le podcast
avec
les capsules humoristiques contre 2 go
quand j'étais plus jeune on écoutait
centre soit vraiment drôle
puis beaucoup l'ont connu avec trois
fois par jour c'est le photographe
alexandre champagne qui travaille avec
son ex copine marie lou son ex-femme
amuserait sur ce projet complètement
monter ce projet l'aude a à z
après sont maintenant en fait il
photographie son studio de photo et des
ateliers
il sentit un livre sur la photographie
sur comment prendre des belles photos
avec son téléphone c'est là qu'ils
peuvent bénéficier à tout le monde pense
tout le monde peut prendre des belles
photos de son cellulaire
un lingot a vraiment réel plaisir de
lavaur podcast c'est super facile
d'interviewer les goûts c'est pour une
question on peut partir pendant 20
minutes par les médis par intéressant
s'exprime super bien c'est un geek un
parcours je te manque est plein
d'affaires qui ont fonctionné tous en
feront fonctionner mes enfants
différents acquis devant l'entrepreneur
intéressant quelque chose quelqu'un
quelque chose à dire de parler santé
mentale aussi lui comment comment il
réussit à travailler sur puis à guérir
des blessures qui avaient puis à
améliorer sa santé mentale finalement
donc est-ce pas vos podcasts encore ben
content ouaip et alex est aussi un gars
qui redonne beaucoup aux gens dans le
besoin que ce soit pour des causes des
causes qui ont mené comme le défi sans
alcool 28 jours en février chez qui a
donné beaucoup de ses droits d'auteur
pour aider justement la lutte contre
l'alcoolisme c'est vraiment une personne
qui redonne à la société puis c'est une
super belle conversation
si vous écoutez en ce moment sur balles
à dos oublié pas nous laisser arrêter
une et cinq étoiles ça fait son bout de
chemin en commentaire
c'est nous écouter sur youtube un
commentaire également abonnez vous à nos
chaînes suivez-nous partout
on a lancé maintenant un deuxième
podcast qui s'appelle sans filtre vip
est disponible seulement sur notre
plateforme pétrone donc si vous n'avez
pas assez de sang filtre à chaque
semaine allez sur notre patron pêcheur
la description le lien dans la
description du podcast on reçoit le plus
souvent possible des invités qui sont
moins connus du grand public mais qui
sont tout aussi intéressants
donc si vous êtes des fans de podcasts
vous l'écoutez plus de 100 filtre
dirigez vous vers la page piquionne
sinon le studio sf on continue à
produire des idées pas de casse de
grande qualité à chaque semaine djedid
en discute notamment adamo le temps ne
juge pas le cas d'un mot d'autres
podcast à venir et je pense qu'on a déjà
assez parlé trop longuement puis on va
laisser la parole à alexandre champagne
donc bon podcast bonne école
[Musique]
[Rires]
alex merci d'être là en fait plaisir ça
aura été longue time coming months
efforts six ont décidé d'abord la plaie
je voudrais pas je tenais à ce que les
élus du ce et la personne ben c'est une
personne face est large j'y croyais pas
encore avant de 3,2
mais j'avoue occupé comme comme tu ne
sembles être supportable mais non j'ai
pas si occupés que c'est comment un
mythe qui m'entourent heynckes le
secteur occupé jusqu'au nom je m'occupe
arrêté non mais depuis depuis mois de
décembre chez dirigé par une solide
grippe au mois de décembre un groupe une
vraie grippe la fièvre est attribuable à
la grippe la fièvre à l'uci n'a pas ce
que j'hallucinais des affaires j'ai
vraiment été malade qui j'ai comme
réalisé que j'avais fait la plus grosse
année de ma vie en 2018 j'ai vraiment
vraiment travailler beaucoup à tous les
niveaux ça a été extraordinaire ça a été
au delà de mes attentes puis au lieu de
me galvanise et ça m'a fait peur un
petit peu parce que je me disais j'ai
été très chanceux c'était comme a sorti
trois fois par jour j'avais besoin
quelque part de démontrer que j'étais
capable d'être on my own j'avais mes
ateliers
j'ai été porte parole du world press
rien à faire j'ai fait beaucoup de
contrôle j'ai fait l'image
toute l'identité visuelle la cage au
complet en photos de bouffe si j'avais
des grosses affaires puis j'ai réalisé
après l'histoire de caroline néron que
qu'on connaît tous ce que ça te fait
rêver tout le monde une bad luck où
personne n'était à l'abri de la
malchance pin
je me suis je pourrais pas rouler toute
ma vie sur une réputation puis sur un
truc qui va être repris par quelqu'un
d'autre éventuellement puis qui va
ticket qui est accessible à tout le
monde que je me suis dit qu'est ce que
je fais en ce moment changer des projets
si je fais j'ai mon studio pas loin
d'ici
je fais des photos je reçois des
familles je donne des ateliers mais j'ai
comme deux ou trois gros projets qui
sont en train d'en occuper
puis je prends vraiment temps pour ça je
prend aussi du temps beaucoup pour ma
famille mes amis des choses comme ça je
veux travailler sur mes relations inter
personnelles je vais travailler sur ma
vie personnelle parce que je lis
délaissé pendant vraiment vraiment
longtemps au profit de mon entreprise
avec marie lou née trois fois par jour
puis au profit de des sous en grosse
partie parce que c'était mon rôle chez
trois fois par jour permanent j'ai
réalisé que c'était un petit le
trésorier je bois comme le mot nigger si
on veut tuer mais pas pendant sens je te
jure stockage mais je suis trouvé de
trouver des manières créatives de faire
entrer des revenus mais principalement
pour payer les gens qui travaillent avec
nous pour pas pour se payer gens
déboulent en europe et des bijoux dans
des coffres viboud n'ont même jamais
jusqu'à maintenant 60 millions ce qui
arrivera parce que je parle et rit mais
je vais m'acheter une boule en en plus
je faisais diront pas de stick mon
éditeur de livres antoine roth trempe là
il dit ci dessus c'est gros comme un une
boule en or de 60 millions j'ai quand
même ça veut dire gigantesque hui fait
d'annoncer sa doivent comme muse remake
simone 50 cm de haut ces facteurs
l'impression que le thon 60 millions
d'or si genre une gigantesque boule mais
c'est juste quand même et on a un ballon
d'omnicane d'une boule de quille en or
d'y aller jouer au kinect à boulemane ce
serait être moins plus ou moins c'est
quand même assez malléable astrosurf
face à se reprendre quelque chose de
plus dur si ça veut pas c'est un élément
qui très mou clore le tout frais du dd
keyyo non-droit dans ta vie non ok t'es
juste un expert de l'or jetant un ex ben
faites moi j'ai un gros j'ai à chaque
gros fan du tableau périodique away les
éléments puissants
spike et ont préféré d'uranium quand
même pas ce qui est assez particulier
comment on fait pour extraire les
auteurs d'uranium dans une centrifugeuse
qui va jusqu'à cette folle intéressant
mais l'uranium en tant que tel il est
pour moi je préfère comme toute la
partie en bois les éléments qui ont été
découverts après la baule à john hyams
ces affaires le ce fascinant pitt y est
tu pourrais pas sur un mur faire tenir
un morceau de chaque élément à côté de
l'autre qui créerait la fin du monde
financier
il défend une présentation des éléments
c'est tellement kiri en laboratoire je
pense que oui je pense pas trop
connaissance de cela mais les autres dit
ça existe en matière physique à part
mettre les gaz qui sont un peu des fois
on entamé mais tu pourrais voler mais
d'un côté de l'autre créerait une
fission nucléaire qui avait pas de bon
sens une chaîne une action qui fera
exploser la planète terre ah ouais c'est
fou que je n'ai pas comme un docteur
terreur qui avait son objectif - bc tu y
vois ça je m'étends j'ai un cerveau
twisted village après cette nouvelle
logique c'est la fin du monde ça serait
un meilleur méchant dans james bond à ce
que plus ça va plus les méchant dans
james bond sont sauf qu'ils lisent les
comme empoisonné l'eau douce et fait
sauter de quoi est vraiment de manière
plus efficace des villes mais aussi
équipé que j'ai mon site web
yves-m je tenterai de me faire un site
web où je vais mettre mes projets photo
parce que le tout sorti d'instagram je
vois aussi mettre à vendre des des
filtres et des bases de retouches pour
les gens qui veulent apprendre la photo
toute ma formation je voulais faire en
vidéo aussi pour tout le monde qui veut
les avons partout à travers la province
ont peut-être faire en anglais aussi tu
es ce que tu vas vendre des des photos
imprimées en cadeau
peut-être mais peut-être pas non plus
vite tellement qu'il cherchait pourtant
des cardigans qu'attiser la fois pour
manger de la soupe je sais pas je pense
pas que mon arrêt
rendu à ce niveau là je me considère
comme un photographe avril je suis bon
je fais des bonnes photos les prennent
c'est comme le step leucate et autres
des print épatant mais c'est un point
avec l'aquarelle agressives pourraient
pas là j'ai eu mal n'importe qui peut
faire les plaines c'est juste que je
trouve que c'est d'offrir une photo
imprimée pour moi c'est un processus et
c'est plus grand que juste faire comme
j'ai fait un beau coucher de soleil
motel médecin papier je veux te le
vendre je m'appelle alexandre champagne
c'est moi je je je travaille jamais sur
mon nom sauf pour évidemment invités
déjà mes ateliers parce que bon je
montre ce que je capable de donner comme
résultat est donc pourquoi je suis en
mesure aussi de l'enseigné mais de tout
le reste je ne joue jamais sur mon nom
je veux vraiment miser sur la qualité de
mon travail puis en tant que photographe
average et des photographes au québec
qui sont mille fois mais hop qui font
sur de leur vie qui travaillent fort moi
aussi j'ai un bon talent mais je me
considère plus comme un gosse d'affaires
aussi bien d'autres stratégies puis un
créatif un créateur plus qu'un
photographe comme tel qui va faire sa
vie fait pour c'est qu'en ce moment je
suis un peu un meeting brainstorm avec
moi-même pour savoir ça va être quoi mon
mon prochain projet mais en même temps
je fais des choses qui me plaisent comme
par exemple pour recevoir des familles
je prends des enjeux sociaux dont je
parle à travers des reportages pour tous
des choses comme ça ça me fait vraiment
tripé gg quand on te fait on annonce que
tu changes de studio et que tu pendant
des tontes et surplus matériaux pour
pour pour redonner magic trouvé ça y est
on est trouvé que c'était un discours
qui s'éloigne est tellement de la
tendance populaire contient en tant que
société de jesper mon succès s'établit
pas un matériel s'est passé rien
pictave elle-même l'humilité de dire mon
trip d'ego je l' ai déjà vécu j'en veux
pull est resté là ça m'a même rien de
plus cités non vraiment post citait
carrément sur le tir jeudi en même temps
ça n'enlève rien aux gens qui décident
de faire
d'acheter des voitures ou des choses
avec leurs sous c'est ça prendre
certaines libertés économiques dans une
société pour que ça fonctionne plus pour
que les gens aient envie de redonner
autrement ben il y en a qui s'en vont
vers des paradis fiscaux des choses
comme ça fait 15 jours que la liberté
économique on a est bonne à pour être
meilleur mais quand même bonne c'est
juste que le choix personnel que j'ai
fait c'est de m'éloigner de ces affaires
là un mime migrants go favoris au monde
sait qu'ils nourrissent qui nourrissent
en secret à financer pour 80 millions de
dollars des hôpitaux pour enfants
c'est un gars qui prend le métro snagit
kitty il s'en fout puis les histoires
commencent à sortir de keanu reeves
huawei en amont pour que les nouveaux
rôles internet info non mais si c'est un
gars qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'ici
je dirais sa fortune est un million de
fois plus grande que la mienne c'est pas
ce faux je veux pas comparer mais tout
est dans l'attitude aujourd'hui tout est
dans l'intention si tout le monde peut
devenir photographe
tout le monde peut avoir un podcast ou
le monde peut faire n'importe quoi tout
est rendu accessible on a démocratisé
l'accès au fait de s'exprimer au fait de
communiquer des choses à tout le monde
moi je pense que ce qui prime la danse
et les intentions que derrière moi c'est
sûr que je trouve ça le fun en maths est
ce là quand je vais faire de ta mise à
part tout le monde sa rue parce qu'ils
trouvent ça et 40 voire un champ
électrique charcoal molle et vitres
teintées aux ressorts de batman mais moi
personnellement ça m'apporte rien si ça
me donne rien de faire ce parce que la
personne que je vois croisé à me connais
pas je la connais pas que j'ai un top up
pour un morceau de métal que j'ai réussi
à payer parce que j'ai eu le privilège
puis la chance d'être né dans une bonne
famille d'avoir rencontré marie lou
d'avoir été entouré d'une équipe
extraordinaire qui m'a permis de faire
des sous et je me dis tiens tout ça
c'est comme du 26 de l'énergie aussi été
veut pas quant à un niveau de vie à ce
niveau là même si tu fais des soupes des
panneaux mais combien de femmes et même
si tu fais des souces cdd pense quand
même je regarde les succès à coude puis
je regarde ce que je pourrais faire sur
le side avec ce pour aider d'autres
personnes je me dis je pense que c'est
mieux investi deux bars loeb puis pour
vrai j'ai trouvé ça le fun à voir des
voitures toutes les voitures que j'ai
voulu avoir dans la vie j'ai eu hélas
c'est comme fini je me lâche j'ai 33 ans
et je vois je vais m'ennuyer investi à
si je continue à voir ce puis peut-être
cac 40 si j'ai mal géré les affaires de
marivaux de bad luck
une scène parce que peut-être que les
gens alexandre champagne les photos ils
vont faire comme on a fait les autres
comprennent fait je pense qu'il faut pas
se prendre au sérieux et c'est le fun
quand ça va bien sauf que tout ce qui
monte redescend
je pense à des photographes que je
connais qui sont extraordinaires qui
travaillent plus aujourd'hui parce que
la forme ans est passible s'est rendu
quelques uns des autres pays les gens se
succèdent des choses comme ça fait que
je me dis je veux réduire mon niveau de
vie de 1 parce que j'ai envie de prendre
mon capital pour investir sur des
projets sociaux que je veux faire et
ensuite de ce bain pour mon niveau de
vie j'ai plus envie d'un élargissent
comprends j'ai envie d'une petite vie
simple puis de me servir le plus
possible de mes ressources autant
méconnaissance ma visibilité mais sous
pour mettre ça au profit de choses qui
comptent plus pour moi et après sa main
ci s'inspire d'autres gens faire la même
affaire tant mieux mais c'est vraiment
pas une leçon quoi que ce soit c'est
juste que c'est mon choix personnel a -
est-ce que c est ce que tu te sentes ici
dans ce changement là un espèce de
légèreté au web je me sens bien dans ton
nom je me suis remis à dormir parce que
jésus était un gay qui dormaient super
bien puis à partir du moment où il est
arrivé l'histoire car le néron je me
suis mis à faire de l'insomnie
j'ai fait ça parce que j'étais comme
j'ai vraiment été kaki en faisant ce jeu
mais les pas de mes affaires
il ya une chose que j'ai que j'ai gardé
de ce discours loeb c'est l'histoire des
taxes les taxes que tu perds
subséquentes et entreprenante devient un
collector pour le gouvernement
les gelées l'argent qu'ils étaient des
taxes tu dois leur donner absolument
soit aux trois mois ou à l'année
ce pour moi c'est primordial la
meilleure forme de philanthropie au
monde s'est payé ses impôts là quand
j'entends des personnes qui sont
extrêmement riches qui veulent être
encore plus riche en allant les paradis
fiscaux
je trouve ça dégueulasse parce que c'est
de l'argent qui va servir à tout le
monde pas juste les gens qui mangent pas
pas juste les gens qui sont malades pas
juste telle catégorie ça sert à tout le
monde à toi à toi à toi ça sert à tout
le monde à monedan ta vie tu auras
besoin d'être va peut-être avoir besoin
d'un coup de main une subvention d'aller
à l'hôpital wever puis ça va être payé
grâce à des gens qui font des sous merci
aux personnes qui sont plus fortunés
évidemment parce qu'il ramasse une bonne
partie de la facture sociale
mais moi je pense que s'il faut
l'importer en fait sur cette parcelle du
disco j'aurais pu la formule est
beaucoup mieux que j'aurais pu ne pas
attaquer personnellement caroline je
n'aurais jamais souhaité qu'on fasse
payer de mots
je souhaite pas les chèques des gens
j'ai pas quelqu'un qui est compétitif je
peux quelqu'un qui est amer dans la vie
mais j'avais une super bonne année
j'étais un peu coquidé ce que j'avais
réussi à faire puis quand j'ai vu ça
j'ai juste comme frappé ben l'autre
affaire aussi c'est l'apparence c'est le
statut ou la glorification des
entrepreneurs c'est le goya se disent
là-bas cinq arrêts centre nc quoi les
dix habitude déjà millionnaire et puis
je vois sur instagram je trouve ça
débile
j'ai peur mais ton de ce que ma fille va
faire de cette information-là qui
complètement ridicule jeudi 8 peut
devenir millionnaire sais c'est pas
interdit à personne de devenir
millionnaire mais c'est pas tout le
monde qui par la même place puis est ce
que tu veux vraiment être milian ans et
sur ton but d'avoir beaucoup de cash il
ya tellement d'affaires foschi qui roule
sur internet des entrepreneurs qui ont
disputé motivations ayant 21 ans ils
n'ont pas eu d'échec dans vie jeu que je
trouve ça un peu débile fait c'est un
peu ce que je voulais defferre où je
voulais commencer la discussion puis
malheureusement j'ai fait quelque chose
qui vraiment pas dans mes habitudes j'ai
pris une personne à partie et j'ai mis
cette personne là dans le milieu de mon
enfant puis je le regrette c'est
carrément signifie gentil a laissé aller
fait ses choix dans vie puis a fait ses
affaires
ce n'est pas à moi de juger puis j'ai
regretté ce j ai parlé on s'est excusé à
me porte pas dans son coeur
c'est tout à fait normal puis j en veux
pas pour ce mais j'aurais dû fermer
mayer ouvrait looking back
je pense que je pense que c'est que ça
son exemple elle représente un peu ce
que ce que tu viens d'exprimer par
rapport à l'espèce de glorification de
du statut plus que deux de plus que de
l'entreprise comme tel plus le comme
l'entrepreneur au delà de l'entreprise
était 6e qui a ramené beaucoup son sort
sa notoriété et son image correcte et a
le droit de faire ça nous c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait pour trouver
par jour je peux pas blanc une personne
décède servi puis je dis ça marche et
ses affaires il ya des gens qui aiment
cinquième ce café puis ces trucs si
c'était de la qualité et puis je dis est
faux pas at il faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain de mort en même temps
il ya quand même une différence qui donc
si on garde les deux exemples de
justement de créer une entreprise comme
trois fois par jour même si tu utilises
déjà tu utilise des noms pour la créer
mais ça reste quelque chose qui apporte
sais pas j'ai commencé tandis que j'ai
jamais vue ni toi ni marilou s'élever en
utilisant l'entreprise en fait ça fait
quand même partie pas grand-chose
d'entente et marilou tu es connu déjà un
public a chanté deux c'est drôle que tu
dis ça parce que il ya des gens qui
disent est assez facile c'est sûr qu'ils
y ont du succès puis toutes sont déjà
connus puis l'autre moitié du monde 10
acres et ça marche a jamais cédé à ce
but c'est quand même drôle témoin je
trouve que vous avez quand même vraiment
construite quoi si oui à chanter mais a
construit de quoi de nouveau à partir d'
absolument rien humaine qui ceci dit
tout à votre honneur je sais qui oui
puis non on est parti de rien on a eu
des investisseurs privés au début que je
remercie encore comme à tous les jours
puis m on à moi j'avais quand même une
base en photographie marouzé longtemps
qu à cuisiner puis ce n'est pas nouveau
non sens où ricardo était le coup de pau
c'était la cuisine futé était là il y
avait plein de gens qui étaient là qui
avait déjà du succès je pense qu'on l'a
fait différemment pin ou comme je disais
tantôt ce qui faisait la différence et
nos intentions l'intention avait trop
fort par jour c'était de transformer
pour le mieux la relation entre la
nourriture et les gens parce qu'il marie
lou avait vécu un trouble du
comportement alimentaire
elle était anorexique de 14 à 18 heures
puis à siguiri un majeur partie parce
que la procurer en apprenant cuisiner tu
comprends ce que les aliments font à ton
corps puis après ce bain décède ou en
tout cas ce que marleau a réussi à faire
ces deux distances et l'image du besoin
du corps fait que on a réussi à faire se
passer de ce don était question puis ici
on le dit pas ouvertement tout le temps
mais le nombre de fois qu'il ya des
mamans et des papas ampleur qui l'ont
arrêté à l'épicerie dans rue au centre
d'achat ou a répondu vous avez sauvé ma
fille vous avez sauvé mon garçon on le
retrouve
si on a trouvé une manière d'être en
famille pour manger ou des choses comme
ça je pense qu'on a fait naître du bond
de soupe c'était seule intention avons
voulu juste part des recettes dont on
avait eu un petit studio puis on aurait
fait
40 recettes par jour où on a engagé du
monde pour faire des recettes pour nous
qui sommes et comme c'était vraiment un
kraft trois fois par jour pendant deux
ans et demi 80 heures par semaine on
faisait un bruit n'est je faisais des
photos on faisait avec sa piste s
non-stop pendant deux ans et demi on
avait pas de vie sociale ares ix et oui
c'est pour ça qu'on est arrivé le spa
parce que rené angélil ou quelqu'un
était derrière nous qui nous a poussés à
tout à fait à faire des affaires sous on
dit il n'ya pas de machine s'était elle
puis moi en bobettes le dimanche occupe
un historien sur 15 l'ont fait pour des
sorties les napperons des affaires parce
qu'on devait payer dumont pour traille
pour nous parce qu'on était dans jules
la demande était forte et ainsi de suite
dit oui on est devenu indépendant de
fortune mais même en ami on a mis les
roulements puis je pense qu'une chose
que fait d'avoir qu'il si le truc c'est
la signature esthétique de ce projet lui
qui était vraiment aux mines qui avait
dû cacher qui était dû au long de toutes
les restes des choses de tout ce qu'on a
on s'est fortement inspiré de ce qui se
fait en europe de ce qui se faisait en
australie aussi d'aider courant de de
photo culinaire puis maintenant c'est
devenu vraiment peu place d'un bon
courant de photos mais si on n'a rien
inventé dans ce sens où on a repris des
affaires on s'est inspiré puis nous ce
qui est important qu'on faisait des
photos c'était pas de faire des photos
de la réussite de faire la photo d'un
moment c'est est d'inspirer les gens à
préparer une belle table pour la famille
pour les amis des choses comme ça fait
quand on se faisait dire à tout le temps
un bon réseau tout le temps parfait vous
visez un autre planète ont noté que non
vraiment pas même je vais faire mon
épicerie en jogging à longueuil comme
respect puis on sait juste que ces
points inspirent-ils j'aurais bien voulu
faire des photos de l'homme dans un
tupperware sur un comptoir de migron
dans une cafétéria
mais comme exposé qui inspire des gens
cuisinent qui nous autres qu'on veut
c'est que les gens apprennent à cuisiner
puis ce serait vraiment envie de le
faire pour vraiment faire une belle tape
et recevoir du monde créé des liens
jaser puisque tout se trouve à paris
on a reçu ici d'une traînée sur bernard
laval élèves le fleuve but quand même
pis ils disaient télé ricardo pelé marie
lupi tels que ceux qui partagent leurs
recettes qui inspire les gens cuisinent
évidemment il ya tellement pour la santé
publique
répandu du bon parce que c'est un des
premiers conseils santé nutritionnelle
c'est cuisiner à la maison c'est plutôt
qu'ils mangent l'alberta
justement tu faisais autre vous avez
désengorger les hôpitaux hôtels vous
avez des manières parmi d'autres mais
d'affronter pour la santé des gens
justement d'inspirer les gens cuisinent
et même un des meilleurs concerts
c'est ça la famille c'était ça le but et
le buste et rien d'autre que de faire
comme en été car et nos jobs respectifs
bon support pour un projet puis c'est
payant tant mieux puis c'est devenu ce
que c'était coutadeur respectives moi
j'ai un enfant j'étais humoriste 2007
tous ces sites a fait l'école de
l'humour j'ai comme a pris ce vraiment
trop tard c'est fait j'ai gradué en 2007
en même temps que françois bellefeuille
mathieu simon gouache ouais bonne année
mais moi je t'ai connu dans le temps
avec contre contraintes que c'est là où
je voulais aller jeter ou sais j'ai même
au secondaire quand ça commence mais
gauclin monsieur jamais vraiment sur vos
cafés de contrat chez cas douteux
qu'elle avait vingt ans il y avait 8 ans
grand cailloux du petit enzo tu me
remets ton jeta this is an tout autre
trempe trouvera maugis 27 pas de
s'immiscer sur tf1 secondaire au cégep
je tripais le jeu vers l'avant
mettons que tu regarde maintenant le
courant des photos de beauf pinto reste
mettons au québec qui est beaucoup
beaucoup de monde qui sont arrivés après
trois fois par jour puis admettons qu
après si tu regardes contre de gueule
puis les capsules web de genre de blog
qui sont arrivés après contre dieu
j'ai l'impression toi même tu t'étais
inscrits dans des courants rapidement
c'est au québec je veux dire d aplomb
sauf vu log mettons le même jour ce
serait l'équivalent maintenant les
humoristes font les capsules ça devienne
la méthode de marketing dans le format
slim et on lit mais tout était early en
tabarnak maugis g partie ma page
facebook en 2007
oui puis quand j'ai bâti ma page
facebook facebook facebook en 2007
ça faisait deux ont dit à vis qui en
appelaient des fan pages
google espère j'ai vu là-bas je sais pas
si j'ai appris comme ça il y en a
sûrement d'autres qui l'ont fait en même
temps mais je peux pas savoir
au québec on en parlait le des clips
humoristiques comme cela il y avait en
même temps que les autres avaient idiot
fortis qui est une série web un peu
comme gameiro tenu dans la main aux
autres puis pas longtemps près nous
aussi il ya eu le truc avec simon
olivier fecteau en audition avec simon
puis avait une cote d'enfer sur youtube
ses jambes fuselées james et en quelle
année avant des afars médiévale grand
dragon les rides ou la peur mais ça
disent c'est comme un des premiers vidéo
virale du québec page facebook faisait
regarder de haut quand j'ai fait surface
les gens trouvaient ça prétentieux avons
une page facebook de parler de la bassée
bout ça me faisait rire un peu quand
j'étais comme un puits aujourd'hui les
gia des gens qui me donnent des sous
pour que je leur explique comment ça
marche puis comment faire et puis je
vais pas dire que j'avais raison gagne 2
caves le sais vraiment pas ce que je
veux dire ce que je veux dire c'est que
pour moi j'ai vu le mais c'était
simplement c'était gratuit puisque la
france qui veut quand il veut
immochan gones même je suis un peu
sauvage dans le sens où si j'ai un
projet mal faits puis mot mais le pays
reste ici parce que jorge j'ai travaillé
intelligent travailleur du moby j'étais
vraiment gossip que les producteurs
disent qu'ils avaient jamais d'argent
mais que tous les producteurs que je
connaisse avec porsche pour un bateau
soit 5 des phoques hinchey puis je
m'excuse je deviens vraiment émotif
quand je parle de dieu parce que si
encore cela réalité on n'a pas d'argent
on n'a pas d'argent mais tous les
producteurs puis plusieurs personnes je
dis pas qui tous les producteurs sont
riches à millions c'est pas ce que je
veux dire mais comme c'est pas vrai
qu'il n'ya pas d'argent c'est juste que
l'argent est selon moi drôlement
distribuer puis encore là c'est du cas
par cas si j'ai fait des trucs où
j'étais très bien pays quand je
travaille chez tva par exemple que mon
temps j'ai un très bon salaire c'était
bien mais comme j'étais tanné de pas
avoir le contrôle sur le contenu je
tenais d'amener puis d'être stimulée par
des idées puis de me faire casser ce
fois que je voulais les données fait que
j'ai fait un amalgame ce que je veux
faire c'est une femme organisée pour
remercier du cash faire mes propres
idées puis après ça je vais faire ce que
je veux dans la vie c'est vraiment ce
fax et c'est venu d'une frustration je
pouvais pas faire ce que j'aimais et je
me suis dit mais je vois pas ce que
j'aime je vais commencer à et des
capsules vidéo genre décrivait un film
de walt disney puis j'ai remonté toutes
les parties dans le désordre comme
cependant jardin excuse moi j'accroche
et ont manqué pendant je mettais tout
dans le désordre ça fait une espèce de
montage un peu fou c'était comique après
ce que j'avais j'ai monté des
personnages leur faisait défaut
documentaire c'est le médium qui m'a
toujours appelé le je m'étais rendu
compte qu'avec youtube un sac ou
terrible toutefois rien dit chan était
populaire puis tu fais des affaires avec
après ça on a fait contre le groupe pee
wee sa partie mais je ne sais pas si
c'est nous qui a donné le coup d'envoi
pour ceux où si c'est le fait que les
gens ont juste fait comme oh my god
un truc gratuit qu'on peut faire je
pense à julien lacroix ouais je viens
que je trouve vraiment vraiment puissant
qui a déjà dit à jour auberge si ma
mémoire est bonne qu'on l'avait beaucoup
inspiré à sa sortie des capitaux si
j'étais content attentif à ce que j ai
vraiment bon et vraiment drôle
hoyé vraiment drôle et ricky fabrique à
18 août moi je me suis-je
j'avais mal à la gorge même tellement je
riais je pensais que j'allais vomir
humanité nager trop les câbles parking
stupide dit j'avais besoin d'être ou ce
vraiment vraiment bon ce qu'ils font pis
c'est juste qu'on a démocratisé l'accès
à la culture à tout le monde puis comme
on va en profiter tout donne le pouvoir
au peuple c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
ça c'est que les gens maintenant
s'approprient ces affaires là autant que
au beurre ou brident trop
airbnb les gens sont comme hey j'ai des
ressources puis je prends faire profiter
d'autres non je peux me ramasser un
saâdane avec subi sa part des carrières
comme dans lequel julien ça change ça
change le statut quo aussi le teen aux
élections l'expérimentent ici avec le
studio lui même afin d'y comme ceux
jamais des podcasts mettons le jamais de
la vie on pourrait avoir les propos
qu'on a les invités qu'on veut le covan
est atteinte à notre show il fallait
qu'on commet des comptes à quelqu'un en
tout cas je sois pas d'accord nous on a
une raison de faire passer si tout avait
le feeling qu'est ce que tu fais ici
c'est la bonne chose à faire c'est
piquant qui disait - n'ont pas sauté de
refaire dans un an
c'est comme arte geie pas garder mes
jobs longtemps et j'ai fait quatre
écoles secondaires à moi je n'étais pas
capable de me conformer jetez pas
capable puis pas de me conformer genre
faute sous l ère de terreur alors jeté
caddies remplis par des chiffres de ce
que je comprends le fait qu'il faut
avoir une discipline honorable des
choses comme ça mais pour moi quand ça
sortait en dehors de mes valeurs
c'était n'offre aucun goût et ça
marchait pas j'ai déjà quitté j'ai
travaillé deux semaines dans un magasin
de vêtements une grande grande chaîne de
magasins de vêtements qui n'existait
plus maintenant puis je me souviens
juste avec un client n'aurait d'iphones
puis jordi j'étais payé un peu la
commission mais c'était jean ridicule je
faisais comme deux scènes d'horreur en
commission puis amener la personne qui
gérait le magasin venu voir perdre le
savoir-faire le sourire puis on s'amuse
un peu moins pessimistes oblige avec 1
850 mille pièces de lingerie main pour
le client le client me regarde et dit sa
tante à xiamen prendre un café avec
chris et solistes je fais de bonnes
idées
le groupe j cole c'est mon cas qui comme
même je me suis j'ai des amis là il
faisait est-il de l'eczéma parce que
c'est trop c'est d'aller porter des
civils chez mcdo qui voulait être pris
parce qu'ils voulaient dans leur service
et a écrit j'ai travaillé chez mcdo
gentil pour m'exploiter hold you want je
vole farabi pour acheter comme oh my god
c'est complètement ridicule man jeudis
du port est fort plus tu pourrais comme
force qu'ils étaient mieux payés plus
puis de ceux qui bossent a jamais été si
c'était comme n'offre aux kings oui je
veux pas me conformer à vos enfants qui
aujourd'hui ce que je fais ça a son lot
de conséquences négatives aussi je
prends goût que la mère discipline au
monde juge son secondaire à quatre types
comme il ya plein d'affaires comme ça
mais je vis ben je suis heureux ici je
veux pas dire aux jeunes lors je serai
grand je n'ai pas travaillé puis voilà
veut c'est super important je pense à
retourner à l'école bientôt parce que
j'ai manqué ça dans ma vie j'étais folle
intéressés par la matière mais je t'ai
j'étais complètement dégueuler par la
manière de l'apprendre puis le fait
qu'il fallait que je reste assis puis
que je fasse comme au québec le
aujourd'hui à prisa fois dont je me
servirai jamais at-il on a on a
construit mon esprit de déduction mon
esprit logique et les mathématiques mais
muscu ce qui me faisait trop piste est
le français l'histoire
puis la musique parce que je vous dise
rome ne veut pas faire ce qu'il fallait
que je fasse des magpies jamais passé
puis comme aujourd'hui je connais les
matchs que j'ai besoin de connaître
pages et des entreprises mais comme
sinon je m'organise bien défection fait
que
j'ai pas j'ai pas garder des jobs
longtemps puis quand je voyais des
milieux où j'étais capable de faire ce
que je voulais quand je voulais j'allais
leur puis je demander l'aide des gens
que j'ai toujours bénéficié d'une belle
grasse et les gens m'ont toujours
encouragée dans ce que je fais et j'ai
toujours des réactions positives fait
que j'ai je suis un chanceux mais la
beauté aujourd'hui c'est que plus besoin
d'attendre de faire repêcher de l'effet
recherché par quelqu'un les hameaux de
données n'djama données fannie mae et
l'émission d'une partie de farce c'est
on a tous les outils faire un podcast
honnêtement si nous on est bien installé
un petit programme l'ambiance est ce par
un podcast c'est peau dure
si c'est pas compliqué c'est 5 faire
construire sont à faire partir une
chaîne youtube c'est pas si compliqué
puis peu importe c'est quoi ce que tu
veux faire tout un moyen de trouver si
l'entrepreneur le capot narnia encore là
c'est pas pour tout le monde il y en a
pour qui c'est un sécurité là où ça
stresse le ca fonctionne repos mais
c'est pour toi pense et c'est pas parce
que où est celle du célèbre c'est bon si
il faut il faut pas non plus banalisée
de seuil c'est ce dont on parle des
entrepreneurs et jusqu'à moi mais faut
pas sous-estimer non plus toutes les
catégories des personnes qui ont des
jobs manuel qui ont des jobs a annoncé
qu'en écoutant n'avait pas de gauche
puis deux filles de construction humaine
on serait dans marbot à peu près de
pitié des ouvriers et il faut pas
oublier qu'on est un tout petit con
dépendent tous les uns des autres
de toutes les manières possibles on
dépend tous les uns des autres pays
comme ça c'est important de le voir fac
oui c'est le fun l'entrepreneuriat pis
tout mais comme comme 6 10 et 18 pour
toi au pot puis moi j'encourage les gens
à découvrir ce qu'ils aiment
je dit pas aux gens partiront en
business dit faux cul à tout le monde
l'attitude que j'avais était pas noble
tant que ce qu'on voit c'est juste que
j'avais pas envie de me conformer
probalement parce que j'ai des douleurs
d'enfant ce qu'ils faisaient en sorte
que je n'ai aucunement capable de
tolérer d'autorité mais je
mais seuls à tolérer plus j'aurais aimé
ça être plus longtemps aux études du
congrès looking back l'hôte ici si je
regarde en arrière je me rends compte
que c'est important de tous considérés
puis décidé à faire puis d'être calme
qui doit le faire patiemment parce que
tu vas trouver éventuellement c'est sûr
et certain il faut juste pas que tu aies
par des séismes commun commente-t-il
avec tout le discours que tu sembles
avoir autour de la façon avec laquelle
l'éducation des pop n'étaient pas
fonctionnels pour toi même façon que
c'était fait c'est quoi ton approche
parce que l'automne fille qui est rendu
qui est que l'on gagne trois ans et demi
il va arriver dans le système
d'éducation éventuellement c'est quoi le
match commentait pas d'appréhension mais
comment tu vois ça arrive et ça change
ta relation à toi avec avec le système
d'éducation puis la façon avec laquelle
l'enseignement est donnée aux jeunes qui
parfois puis moi je suis ça résonne
beaucoup ce que tu dis dans mon
expérience à moi la bonne chose que je
pense par études sinon je me serais
jamais jamais fait comment tu comment tu
vois sur mettons maintenant du point de
vue du père c'est je dis souvent marie
lou qui est la mère de ma fille
concrètement si j'ai déjà entendu des
rumeurs comme quoi ma jeanne n'était pas
ma fille ni les autres les rumeurs le
pili magazines à potins boucher dans une
secte j'adore ce quand je lis ce jeu
compte de ça vaut que on occupe l'espace
de l'esprit de certaines classes un sens
parce que c'est parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui peuvent pas concevoir
qu'un coupe ça vaut mais si je peux
comprendre
je peux comprendre jeudi est assez
terrible en général ce qu'on voit dans
les coupes les séparations les divorces
les applications pour des télés fait de
consommer des personnes je plonge je
comprends pourquoi ces gens le pansement
et puis j'ai absolument qu'on peut
comprendre tout ça fait ça me force pas
pantoute le lot ça me fait juste
vraiment
bref pour ma fille je dis souvent
marilou j'ai dit je veux j'aimerais ce
qu'on soit ensemble tout le temps toutes
les rencontres de parents habitent ce
parce que moi j'ai eu des professeurs
des éducateurs spécialisés qui n'ont pas
été fantastique avec moi je vais pas les
blancs mais de rien je peux les accusés
je vois jamais les nommer ou quoi que ce
soit mais j'ai eu des expériences à
l'école qui était vraiment traumatisant
comme accusé de vendre la drogue on m'a
accusé d'être voleurs des choses que je
faisais moi je la sers fois je fais ici
je faisais le conte d'un classe pendant
les cours parce que je m'emmerdais je me
faisais des petits bonhommes à snowboard
que je puisse noter sur le monde
je faisais des dessins j'ai écrit des
partitions de rome mais je t'ai pas de
délinquants je me battais pas je prenais
pas de drogue
je me bat i comme je t'ai pas un
délinquant comprend puis dans ce temps
là les colts avaient bon élève ou
délinquants fait que j'ai fait plusieurs
écoles toujours presque jamais le thème
est la bonne élève
j'ai lâché que de mon secondaire sans
que je pense à les 80 jours sur 190 le
moment baptisé mes absences puis je dors
je préviens que parce que j'aï ses
sabots mort et ta mère avait abandonné a
dit que lui
on les nomme et il faut connaître
l'histoire complète peut-être un jour de
la rencontre et mais comme j'ai des
affaires épouvantable gens mais parce
qu'ils sont il faut mener mes parents
l'école puis il rencontre des parents
sont comme on pense qu'alexandre vend de
la drogue puis mon parquet comme what
the fuck même monfils prend même pas de
drogue c'est comme une peau question qui
jamais n'a jamais fait si affectif c'est
vraiment rageant pour des parents le qi
notre lot bref ça a été très très loin
après ceux dans la commission scolaire
veut pas que j'ai dit à marie lou ces
jeux puis on dirait que je suis comme un
peu content dans une petite fille de son
audi que les garçons sont plus
turbulents je veux pas croire à ça parce
que je veux que si on parle beaucoup de
l'égalité des sexes puis on peut
retrouver un comportement chez eux ou
chez l'autre puis après seul le spectre
du genre et compagnie c'est pas des
choses avec lesquelles je suis très à
l'aise dans ce sens où je connais pas ça
beaucoup qu'est ce qui se dit c'est quoi
les bonnes affaires se fait mais j'ai
quand même con et expérience d'achat 15
il était temps eu plus de gotham
alexandre cinquième année nettement mon
prof aurait eu besoin d'un gones pour
nous chères
si même pas des jo on est l enfer mais
l'enfer je serai comprend pourquoi
puis je le salue je pense qu'il est
encore en vie sylvain basque mon
professeur de cinquième année que j'ai
adoré mais à qui j'ai fait vivre un
enfer avec alexandre caron jonathan bref
c'est ça aussi ça puisse arriver je veux
convaincre des braves parce que je veux
voir comment les prolonger avec ma fille
d'un autre côté je me mets à la place
des profs aujourd'hui son souper
hippiques ont des classes surchargées
je peux comprendre écoute moi je donne
des ateliers à du monde pays pauvres qui
ont envie d'être là c'est divertissant
comme contenu parce que ça leur permet
de repartir à la maison avec des
connaissances qui sont intéressantes
pour l'époque à laquelle on est je
trouve ça chiant parce que j'en donne 12
par jour deux jours de ce fait que je
fais je fais 12 heures en une fin de
semaine à 20 personnes je parle non-stop
pendant trois heures je trouve ce jeu
pas épuisé job en berne ou à rêver je
trouve ça l'fun gm souffrent sur mes
forces à tous les jours devant une
classe de 30 élèves qui ont des vues
d'être là pour la plupart ont même pu
ouvrir chapeau aux enseignants puis si
mes textes peuvent permettre sinon
textes peuvent leur permettre de gagner
plus cher
foxman il est vraiment temps qu'on fasse
quelque chose parce que ça aucun sens du
mot je vais envoyer ma fille à l'école
publique n'est pas question que je dise
quelle école privée ou ou que c'est des
élites puis d'en faire un team ma fille
afrobasket vraiment si elle veut devenir
couturière ou qu'elle veut faire des
bijoux pour les chevaux je m'en crisse
je vois les écoles c'est la fois j'aime
le plus dur et moi je te vois faire des
bijoux pour les chevaux cmn qui rythme
demain les gouttes et finit dans sport
une entreprise on appelle ce diamant
crinière et il m'a fait offense qu'avait
va faire ce qu'il veut et puis c'est pas
un problème j'ai calé à l'école publique
ont un très bon système d'éducation
je pense que c'est fait pour la majorité
c'est fait pour la moyenne ce que plus
tu es un gros groupe plus dur semble à
la moyenne donc les gens qui sont aux
extrémités on parle d élève surdoué ou
des enfants qui sont sous doués
mais je ne sais pas encore j'ai pas
parce que ça fait longtemps que j'ai
prêté dans le système scolaire
évidemment je sais pas c'est quoi
l'efficacité des ressources qui est pour
ces gens là moi je t'ai surdoué à
l'école je tripais sur la musique je
m'emmerdais 100% du temps avec eux
j'avais notre plaisir parce que je
comprenais rapidement fait je savais que
je pouvais juste avoir 80 dans un examen
jeudi que les questions que ça me tente
d'être fâché calculé mon score je
faisais les questions puis j'avais 80
fait que j'aurais pu avoir un mais je
manque en lice et c'est combien j'avais
pas d'intérêt à être là je comprenais
pas excusé je comprenne épaules le
concept mat y était un jeune garçon de
12 13 ans tu passe par des changements
puissent se fait que c'est elle c'est
multifactoriel le système d'éducation
on donne pas les ressources aux profs
pour qu'ils aient du fun avec les élèves
des souvent j'entends des stages et des
gens qui m'écrivent beaucoup pour se
confier à moi je sais pas pourquoi
j'attire ça j'imagine puis j'ai des
preuves qui disent ah et si jamais ça
serait le fun quand on donne deux ou
trois trucs pour la photo j'ai acheté
des affamés sujet comme de quoi acheter
des affaires pour tous et à demain mais
on n'a pas de budget à l'école fait que
j'ai acheté de 3 à faire c'est plutôt
depuis que j'ai fait ça en fin de
semaine c'est la fille allen famille des
jeux à la du temps passe et que sa
famille depuis la fin de semaine à prend
du temps pour ces élèves qui allait y
avoir réussi une c'est comme une
vocation puis on dévalorise la banque et
rassembler d'enseignants puis même à
faire avec les infirmières même chose
avec les postes de gens qu'on a besoin
moto le matin bleu il ya un bateau qui
part pour aller sur une île où on
recoupe la tâche paul le nombre est un
registre à rien si je fais des photos de
cupcake man qui se passe là bas je suis
drôle je peux raconter des histoires je
peux faire des niaiseries un peu mais
c'est pas la chose la plus utile jeu par
la fondation d'une société en s'entiche
la cerise sur le sundae qui comprend
chilin le gréviste sur l'east river mais
comme je trouve qu'on dévalorise
beaucoup de gens le pis j'ai peur de
voir dans quel genre de système mafieux
wait see a pas de changement qui sont
opérés rapidement parce que là les trois
ans et demi avec dans un admis avoir
entré à l'école sur la maternelle 1re 2e
bon je pense que ça va mais les profs
sont l'eau des puits en plus avec toute
la question de la laïcité est ce qu'on
va perdre des enseignants à cause de
leur douleur
affiliation religieuse ou éleveurs c'est
un jugement je fais ce que vous voulez
dans la vie mais comme je me demande
dans quel système j'ai envoyé ma fille
fait que je sais que ma fille parce
repas par les mêmes choses que moi parce
que je vais lui apprendre de mes erreurs
mais je me demande ça va être quoi le
système si on bouge pas plus pour
adapter ce système là au plus grand
nombre de gens possible à l'extérieur de
la moyenne
jacques bouyssou on veut tous un trou un
système où est ce que tout le monde peut
développer son plein potentiel tic que
tu sois dans la moyenne que tu as un
surdoué
que tu sois je te demande à des
difficultés d'apprentissage plus j'ai
l'impression que peut-être les surdoué
d'un côté son hypothèse d'un système qui
par dapd et pour eux parce que ça
devrait aller plus vite le mans de ces
listes non mais sans mobilité comme toi
tu es du ph aussi en fait on était mon
cas beckham la facilité mais qui était
aucune motivation piqué puis surtout
donné valoriser ces jeunes là qui à
l'école présentement avec un cerveau qui
est surdoué ça emmerde mais se
dévalorise même nuit tu es bon tu es le
meilleur appui tout mais est ce que ça
donne vraiment confiance en toi moi je
pense que plus ou moins parce que tu
vois que tu es pas capable de se
conformer à ce fait je me dis mettre à
profit le talent de ces gens là pour les
gens qui apprennent moins rapidement
essayé d'avoir des parts et d'angers
puis sûrement qui en a déjà
je parle un peu à travers le japon en ce
moment parce que je ne connais pas les
ressources que dans les écoles je serais
vraiment vraiment curieux de savoir mais
je pense qu'on peut s'asseoir en
gamecube histoire mais moi c'est ma
force les idées dans la vie quand quand
je brainsonic moi je trouve plein
d'idées comme j'ai des idées dans la vie
pour un instit pas kadhafi qui ont par
rapport à james allait développer les
uns après les autres tranquillement pas
vite mais je me dis ici on prend du
monde brillant leur une fin de semaine
ont fait un congrès on met tout ça bout
moulin dans une salle puis commis un
micro au centre qui viennent nous donner
des idées
les professeurs des gens sur le terrain
presti de trois personnes dans un
cabinet à québec ou à ottawa qui disent
ah qu'il est bon mais on attend plus on
peut fort et ans et quand qu'est ce qui
motive les jeunes qu'est ce qui va les
faire en sorte qu'ils vont vouloir être
en santé
qu'est ce qu'il va faire en sorte qu'on
va voir un psy comme men c'était si ces
lits c'est les semences qu'on plante à
l'envers pour confère tous et la forêt
de la prochaine génération c'est
tellement important
puis on sent
moi je certain qu est ce que tu décris
l'est ça existe des jeux certain que
kate sayid du monde qui se passe les
questions qui comme en campagne arrive
systématiquement qu'on peut relancer
plus efficace comment qu'on puisse
assurer la réussite de plus d'élèves
possible chose ça existe moi je pense
que la seule chose qui manque c'est les
ressources et les télés dans les écoles
y passer des psychologues passer de tout
s'est passé de ressources de salaire des
gens de fond pour que tout le monde
passer du local passe et c'est parfois
juste quelques hommes le budget total du
goûter de l'argent qu'on nomme la
société fala mais plus le seul à
l'endroit le plus important mais ceux ci
a en même temps tout le monde en tout
les secteurs vont à 0 amène tous en
avoir un peu d'argent puis le petit
monde veut venir et les croates de son
bob c'est normal parce que on voudrait
tous devraient tous faire mieux dans ce
domaine respectif
mais s'il ya une job comme tu dis qui
est qui
sous valorisé si le dob d'enseignants
c'est le métier le plus important dans
une société qui justement this battre
s'ils sont en berne les jeunes commence
puis après deux ans ils font ce métier
le sapad à l'heure pile et partent en
voyage parce que justice pour la vie que
je remets tcc c'est vraiment aux petits
dés autant pour celui commencerai ma
tante ch'ti qui tombe à la retraite à 65
ans puis que kata kéké fatigué même plus
capable ce titi je pense à ma prof de 4e
année micheline qui est quand même assez
large et quand l'enseignant soixantaine
d'années petits as le dvd disque de 4e
année qui veut juste aller jouer dehors
depuis jeudi va donner je comprends pour
micheline mène aujourd'hui je pense à
elle
25-26 voulons entreprendre en classe le
30 enfants à gérer puis tu participes à
petite échelle à ce qu'ils vont devenir
dans le futur moi une chance qu'il ya eu
des bons profs
pendant mon parcours je me suiciderai
toujours de ma professeure de 3e année
quand je suis partie de montréal je suis
aller m'installer avec ma mère nos
marges mavs à lachenaie
puis-je est arrivée à l'école l'école
arc-en-ciel à lachenaie dans le
carrefour des fleurs qui s'appelle
terrebonne maintenant si béatrice en 3e
année était tellement douce cette manne
à comprenez l'impression mamadou leurs
deux petits gars qui voulait juste
sauter ses murs puis faire pleine
affaire qui était super douce avec nous
puis ça m'a redonné confiance en les
adultes ni un peu plus tard au
secondaire reno gad est mon prof
d'histoire au collège saint jean vianney
secondaire ont boosté gaulle est il
rentré le premier cours qui donnait une
montée c'est le bureau il ya dix ans ils
criaient l'histoire c'est la vie moi
j'avais vu le film dead poets s'allie
avec de nouveaux viennent ce qui est un
peu le même genre ils renault faisait
des années avant il est toujours
enseigné comme substance dynamique
ça m'a redonné confiance qu'ils avaient
des adultes des gens dans la vie qui
allait guider adéquatement
parce qu'ils comprenaient ou un fait que
j'avais delumeau puis j'avais j'avais du
père puis j'étais effervescents j'avais
envie de tout faire
puis ça ça m'a vraiment aidé mais
autrement
quand je suis rentré au cégep je suis
rentré 1 sciences humaines profil de
gestion puis jetée rue dans un cours de
français à maps a duré une session a pas
ce que j'allais en or et la traiter
ratures jusqu'à fin puis m il ya un mais
prof en français le cours obligatoire si
les cours obligatoires français
habituellement une personne seule
le prof y avait il ya vingt ans qu'il y
avait la misère a gagné la classe city
la semaine en semaine
il y avait de la misère à voir la
tension tout le monde fait kahn est
arrivé avec une guitare puis ai dit que
j'étais un jeune stagiaire déjà 20 prof
qui m'a dit quand la classe écoute pas à
milito qui chante jean leloup plus il
met à chanter les tonnes de jean leloup
qui ont analysé texte jean leloup pis
moi j'ai fait j'ai compris littérature
sur la piste et après ça j'ai fait
qu'ils aient plus de la gestion ça me
fait chier lui il ya quelque chose là
dedans qui m'a dit que je trouve cool
skropeta vie serait millionnaire 1
milliard aux frères moi j'ai noté des
systèmes d'éducation hisser son crayon
il écrit comme ce qui était son crayon
j'ai fait de grosses sommes
il écrit comme ceux à qui puis lui
commence à dessiner mais il y avait un
an et demi depuis des semaines et des
pirates et des enfants orbi taxi il
manie le crayon d'avant et dessiner des
enfants vraiment bien maintenant il fait
du cinéma
mais ce qui fait encore si story board
s'y dessine moi qui avais un métier
vraiment un talent pour le dessin
incroyable pi parti à manier déjà le
crayon bien avant d'écrire explique
credit a réveillé en maternelle première
année pelisse met à écrire puis le les
profs menace peu comme ce qu'on sait son
crayon c'est comme cela qu'ils essayent
de prendre un crayon mais ça marche pas
ça marche pour les premières années du
zaman et la prof n'annonce pas comme ça
quand un crayon comme ça comme ça
jusqu'à ce qu'ils payent nicole en
quatrième année qui dit ça marche fort
puis tout les profs avaient essayé de
changer sa manière publique pas capable
ça marchait pas la partie compagnie
nicole qui est fait genre tamanar est
différente mais ça marche
bozic 7 la précieuse les autres profils
ont laissé sacré patience parce que
nicole comme dit touche pas je trouve
c'est déserter
parce que t on de l'école sur un maul
qui l'ont construite dans un monde
mythique inquiets du monde qui arrive
qu'ils disent ce correct à différents
genres
pis si ça marche pour toi si tu coules
facilement vraiment il y avait à bali
une école qui s'appelle la green school
c'est comme une école mondialement
reconnu et beaucoup de beaucoup de
parents qui ont des moyens qui déménage
à bali pour pouvoir donner cette
éducation là d'un enfant peut
apparemment c'est comme décolle vraiment
c'est vraiment fruits leurs fruits
spirit t'arrive l'ofppt les enfants et
des profs pour les aider dans leur
cheminement mais les profs sont pas là
pour enseigner nécessairement thaksin
comme le jeune fait un projet lui même
puis le prof est comme une ressource le
team pour développer ce qui a envie de
développer puis m
si j'imagine que ça fonctionne si 6e du
monde qui vont le site du monde qui
continue à vouloir ce petit jeu je sais
pas quel point c'est fondamentalement le
système est à revoir
ou c'est juste le support comme tu dit
tout à l'heure qui a augmenté
est ce que notre système parce que moi
je crois que de s'asseoir pendant six
heures par jour pour un jeune s'asseoir
dans une classe du mois je crois pas que
c'est la façon de fonctionner de seppi
je pense que ce au delà de même si les
preuves sont les meilleures conditions
même si tout le monde une meilleure
un meilleur salaire des meilleurs moyens
des meilleures ressources
j'ai l'impression que le système de base
et de la manière d'acquérir une
information d'apprendre ma sauce
ben ça veut dire maintenant tu es rendu
un expert de la du tableau périodique
les ouais je suis persuadé que je
comprends la consultation ou est ce que
je me souviens de la chimie sa garde a
c'est l'expérience la grosse crotte
censier c'était une chaise au secondaire
mène en cours de chimie et a fait qu'
aujourd'hui en faire l'expérience de la
grosse crotte les premiers éléments qui
est notre affaire qui met ça dans un
méchant que ça fait une réaction
chimique
grosskreutz à ce qui se dit et puis tout
ça c'est la chimiste de celle à chagny
comme toi j'ai vraiment plus tard je
fais et la science est intéressant c'est
le fun plus je me suis dit que ma faut
la prendre par moi même
dans le secondaire quand tu es jeune
c'est dur de voir l'utilité derrière les
choses quitte à prendre un peu ses gains
dans le jeu et le messie du site est
fasciné par contre c'est l'ex à
lemouchia fasciné par la science j'ai
fait sciences physiques chimiques à 36
j'ai adoré ce jeune trip est ma vie de
savoir combien vais te trompes proton
baliser les mains puis commence à
fonctionner la masse atomique et
compagnie mais comme ça mais pas utiles
aujourd'hui je comprends c'est pas
quelque chose que je veux me servir mais
je trouve ça vraiment le fond de
l'apprendre mais séparément l'écho qui
me gardaient le avec le français le
français je tripais ma vie puisque pour
moi c'est primordial de notre langue
pour la préserver puis c'est pour moi la
préservation de la culture française de
la langue française et québécoise ne
passe pas tant que c'est par la loi
soeur mais bien plus par par l'amour de
la langue qu'on va transmettre aux
élèves et non le fait de le crise aidant
gorge des immigrés c'est pour moi le
sait bien plus comme si ça fonctionne il
faut que tu apprennes doucement une
personne n'a aimé une chose qui est
extra c'est extraordinaire la langue
française une des langues les plus
complexes au monde
puis comme elle est belle puis moi quand
j'entends de thoune en français ne
brille est une mine comme n'importe
quelle bonne toune en français défense
une excellente tourner en anglais parce
que c'est
l'anc et qui est pas évidente à bien
faire sonner de manière mélodique qui s
il faut l'important c'est beaucoup mais
j'espère la chimie c'est ce que c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas on trouvait que
c'était pas important de l'apprendre ce
que je dis c'est que on dirait je sais
pas prendre moins que les profs ont
essayé faire ça mais j'ai jamais compris
tu y mettons que ce soit dans les cours
d'histoire c'est l'histoire aujourd'hui
je considère son ultra important de
connaître l'histoire du québec pitié ils
sont limités en général péter je trouve
ça plus tard tir en tant qu'individu et
en tant que peuple savoir d'où on vient
ça fait connaître mieux savoir où on
s'inscrit justement dans le monde dans
l'histoire où on s'envole sopi mais à
l'époque un jeu de cartes qui que ce
soit de savoir si sans jamais me servir
cpie pidcp tad qui y est peut-être
qu'elle est le boute voient ce qu'elles
peuvent te dis surtout d'apprendre selon
sa voix de servir dans la vie
associative
parce que moi j'ai parce qu'au cégep on
avait des cours des mois je suis dit en
musique dans le fond cgpm la vie des
cours de littérature musicale
ceux ci justement l'effort la musique sa
part au moyen âge on apprenait en
grégorien cap classique romantique et
hétéros qui la plupart du monde il sert
à rien
côté littérature musicale je vais aller
presse qui en instrument ça ça va me
servir tout ce aller le prof avait dit
c'est l'écouté des termes très musical
c'est important si ça vous donne une
culture un bagage musical puis faire de
la musique c'est pas juste être bon son
instrument c'est aussi connaître ta
musique tu es pour créer il faut
connaître ça va faire que tu voi en
entrevue qu'il faut avoir une culture
mais ce qu'il faut être capable de
parler de musique c'est pô juste de ta
petite affaire métiers de titres
capables d'aller chercher des éléments
composent un élément que jean sébastien
bach peu d'éléments des musiques
médiévales pitch créé quelque chose
d'incroyable exception dans ce que ça
sent le times musicale parfaite mais oui
si c'est pas fou ce harper
le plus notre culture générale mieux
c'est selon - et pas nécessairement
toujours utile mais des fois aucun cas
justement je réfléchis avec moi même je
me fais des bristols loin dans les
affaires là parce que tu es j'ai lu des
trucs moches très peu de national
geographic documentaire je me pose des
questions à tout le monde nous attend
quelque chose que je connais pas je pose
des questions trouveront bientôt être
que j'ai en train de mettre sur pied mon
projet j'ai choisi le thème de mon
prochain projet photo que je veux faire
c'est sûr le tout l'univers des
personnes trans et quand je dis univers
les personnes trans je peux dire qu'ils
vivent dans un univers à part mais je
veux dire si ce tintin
quand je prédisant un enjeu pour moi que
je connaisse 0.2 barre vraiment impôts
je sais pas comment on dit adéquatement
par exemple une personne qui est née
biologiquement un homme qui est devenue
une femme est ce qu'on dit à une femme
trans is conduit une excuse dit que
c'était un homme où ça a toujours été
une femme et le lieu vraiment le corps
qui est loué l' des outils comme je sais
que je vais aller poser des questions
mais j'ai pas prendre d'infliger au
début je ne sais pas mais qui pour moi
envie a pas de mauvaise question plutôt
des faucons on a peur on est gêné de
demander pour les jeunes et je ne sais
pas tu sais surtout pas de faire des
sujets qu'on sait que aujourd'hui c'est
quand même un sujet qui est au tce qui
chope l'once du mélange et je veux pas
utiliser un mot de peur de me faire
reprocher de l'avoir utilisé de peur de
pas utiliser le bon terme ou à l inverse
je vois galvaudé je veux faire du jour
je vois spin et sur un mot je vais faire
du guy bach dessus pour me me donner de
la notoriété fascinant que je connais
quelque chose pour faire du marketing
s'effectue toujours un couteau à double
tranchant de ce genre d'affaires le mais
je trouve ça important de poser des
questions des invités puis moi j'ai
toujours été très et on parle et
d'adultes modèle tantôt avec le prof
nicole de notre ton frère qui lui a dit
mais tu peux écrire demain je trouve que
c'est important pour un enfant d'avoir
les bons modèles et moi j'avais beaucoup
beaucoup d'admiration pour les adultes
parce qu'il savait tellement d'afren
que je me disais whaou quand je dois
être plus vieux moi aussi je veux savoir
des affaires c'est moi j'aime ce
vieillard parce que je suis moins en
moins con ce que j'ai dit à ma mère j'ai
des années autour de manga devoir à 34
je suis vieux je n'en ai pas vu une
entité est à peine à faire de lui un
chef ou tu demandes à une personne de 60
ans c'est quoi ta meilleure époque sens
comme en 45 50 2d sous ta du temps puis
bête josé c'est pour tout le monde je
sais que des exceptions mais je disais
en général si tu arrives dans une époque
de ta vie ou est-ce que tu étais moins
stupide notre commune c'est comme ça que
je vois
jr d'avoir 50 ans pour que les jeunes
prennent au sérieux la 33e je vais faire
une conférence je vais vous expliquer
comment ça marche
une personne qui veut dire oui bonne
idée estimé comme j'ai rien véhicules g
8 g des affaires exceptionnelles qui
sont arrivées dans ma vie mais pas assez
pour rendre une audience pourrait coûter
bientôt la guerre c'est ce qui était
d'avoir le tour enfin pas de casque et
boucar diouf dépit de l expression
québécoise que je préfère c'est
l'expression je me couchais moins
niaiseux en soirée c'est comme c'est
vraiment un désir les taux de base signé
juste un peu moins niaiseux exactement
c'est ça la vie qui capte la drive si je
pense que tout de même toutes les
machines même d'abord la drive
d'apprendre à toutes les journées d'été
je connais pas grand chose mais à sorges
en apprend un peu plus que yara qui a
pillé à chaque jour justement couches
moins niaiseux huszti puis a
manifestement 30 à 40 à 50 c'était comme
l'expérience salon une bonne heure le
tri puis on parle souvent de choisir de
connaissances matériel dans ce sens on
apprend l'histoire on apprend le
français on apprend les mathématiques
mais je trouve qu'on est de moins en
moins portés par les connaissance
spirituelle plus je veux pas parler de
cristaux et de sortie sont arrosés moi
ça me fait halluciner man conques en
confiant aux otages
non mais les appels se casse justement
les gosses justement mais vous trouvez
deux autres passants mais fait que tu
trouves pas que l'astrologie ça revient
en bonne forme tout le monde parle de
tout et d'autres boutiques on en passe
sa mère également parce qu'il ya
tellement de gens qui fustige la
religion mais qui vont diriger ses
proches même aujourd'hui huit manches et
gignac
premièrement ces bases sur une carte du
ciel qui était bonne le milan qui on
s'entend parce que ce qui arrive dans
l'univers c'est que les choses bougent
et elle tourne fait ça veut dire que la
carte du ciel sur lesquels ont été
baptisés principe le ca existe plus et
plus de même fait que ça veut dire
qu'ils avaient à peu près un mois de
décalage environ sur ce qu'on dit pauvre
est ensuite pour moi c'est pas de la
spiritualité
le hasard plus à faire de même comme tu
peux pas les contrôler et il le tarot le
dire à qui bon mais moi il ya jusqu'à
présent de maman est allée voir une
voyante puis la voyant pas le dire moi
par exemple je crois pas non mais je
sais pas sur quoi tu comprends mais je
suis un peu subjugué parce que la fille
elle dit à ma mère
saga n'est pas moins bon mais la rente a
dit ta belle fille est enceinte et fort
que si on l'avait même pas et encore on
l'avait pas dit publiquement que marilou
est ancien ensuite à dix avant d'être le
17 décembre entre 7h et 10h observé t
mfi effective ça va être une fille ce
correct 50 50 % de chances de la vo mais
la journée pilotes alors que mario était
dû pour le 25 je pense la journée pilot
à mon goût j'en ai mis à 9 heures le 17
décembre le jour je regardais l'horloge
puis je check est jetée comme non ça se
peut pas même si c'est impossible que l
a été sais-tu jazz à je ne sais pas tout
ça pour dire que je trouve quand on
s'est éloigné des connaissances
spirituel on a enlevé les moments où se
rassemblaient pour commune y est
ensemble ce deuil
je trouve que ton comportement il est
ordinaire c'est comme il ya pu on appuie
l'église on n'a plus la religion puis
c'était quand même la dernière ressource
qu'on avait de rassemblement c'est sûr
que c'était dirigé par des personnes qui
avaient des intentions à propos vraiment
noble nécessairement c'est quand tu fais
un voeu de pauvreté un évêque m'étonne
bas qui vaut 20000 places puis disais
aux gens c'est resté pieux et puis 98
tout à dessouder steed
de chasteté puis ils ont quitté avec des
tubes des enfants affectés si je peux
comprendre que les gens ont repoussé la
religion mais dame à mon sens un monde
on a jeté le bébé avec l'eau du bain
parce que je pense que c'est important
de se rassembler en un gain de se dire
nos vérités dit comme je n'ai pas de
quoi on et collègues de travail physique
comme un ph
jai vraiment c'est quand il fait des
jobs sur mes cheveux non je te dis n'est
vrai quoi comme ceux ci spirituel c'est
spirituel de parler aux gens de leurs
défauts les d'espérer 2 qui travaillent
sur leurs qualités mais aujourd'hui ça
passe par des enfants qui n'ont pas de
bon sens genre je veux pas dit que le
yoga pas de bon sens merci au chef du
gouvernement en personne
non c'est juste plus flexible comme la
spiritualité c'est le travail de
l'esprit
ici on pouvait promouvoir autant le fait
de travailler sur son esprit la thérapie
des livres des médicaments pour
certaines personnes qui en ont besoin
pour bien fonctionner en société leur
donner un coup de main pour les ramener
avec nous autres autant qu'on promouvoit
le fait d'avoir des abdos puis déboule
en béton mais maintenant ce serait
tellement des meilleures sociétés parce
qu'il ya bondi pour ça beaucoup à nos
enfants
l'on commence à parler d'anxiété moi
j'ai commencé à faire des crises de
panique j'avais 18 ans j'étais un
extraterrestre comme athée fatigué
j'aime son jeu peu fatiguée pendant une
heure je pense que je veux être le next
big thing dans le monde tout le monde
veut connaître votre multi trilliard
d'heure puis après ce bain j'ai
l'impression que je la perds mer dom on
ne sait pas ce qui se passe même j'ai
comme un changement qui n'a pas de bon
sens qui est ce qui se passe mais j'y
travaillais sur mon esprit pendant 11
ans puis j'ai guéri de l'anxiété de
l'angoissé des gens disent info tu
t'habilles dessus puis je regardais
publication est agréable autrefois la
personne demandé c'est quoi votre truc
pour couper avec l'anxiété ambiante
comme ab je vais lire un livre objet
offensif jeter comme il ya personne qui
parle de thérapie une personne qui parle
de lire sur le sujet il ya personne qui
parle d'un docteur qui a trouvé une
manière de de pnl de pays aride des
trucs insipides ça me faisait capoter
parce que même si on parle beaucoup des
maladies mentales
c'est comme devenu un peu une manière de
montrer qu'on était impliqué on n'a pas
vraiment idée de comment on va faire ce
puits ma copine à travail en santé
mentale chez les adultes
dans un truc qui s'appelle les services
intensifs dans le milieu avec des
personnes qui ont encore des maladies
mentales graves schizophrène bipolarité
des choses comme ça a fait des routes va
pas apporter des médicaments puis être
en contact avec ces gens là sur une base
quotidienne puis comme la maladie
mentale c'est vraiment pire qu'on pense
honnêtement puis je trouve qu encore
dans des émissions dans des trucs
d'affaires publiques
on banalise et si je pense une émission
qui s'appelle huissier ou je sais pas
quoi os qui évince du monde de leur
affaire puis ils vont un gros cas de la
personne qui pète une coche mais c'est
une personne qui a des troubles de santé
mentale fait chris tu peux pas avoir
belle cause
au mois de janvier février et après se
diffuse une émission même où est-ce que
tu tu démontes une personne qui était en
détresse d'apathie cette personne elle
est en détresse hypo une crise de folles
est en détresse à leurs besoins deuil
depuis comme si seule angoisse l'anxiété
a beaucoup plus petite échelle que la
bipolarité ou la schizophrénie
évidemment mais comme pour guérir sa
prendre la thérapie ça prend du travail
sur soi ça prend de l'éducation et des
connaissances spirituel si on n'en parle
pas souvent dit gg j'ai évidemment
quelques idées sur le sujet que je
dévoilerai un moment donné mais comme ça
je trouve que ça manque dans leur
éducation
est ce que parce que le mot spirituel et
souvent que noté m si on appelle ça
intelligence émotionnelle a absolument
pas ce que je vais peut être tout à fait
raison des cris de zafour du petit
décrivait l'intelligence matériel qu'ils
ont été le genre de connaissances plus
intelligent spirituel puis on avait une
une conversation avec antoine olivier
pilon qui tomberait oui les jeunes
aimeraient lui in the hills est
subjuguée par par son intelligence
émotionnelle vraiment y échangent par
les chocs de la communication parce que
lui a fait un jardin d'ateliers
s'appelle communication consciente et
qui sait quoi puis tu lui expliquer tout
à l'heure de jeu s'asseoir et un peu ce
que ce que j avais jamais pensé comme ça
mais que l'église pouvait amener où le
confessionnal pour bell et confessionnal
- parce qu'il y était question de
punition en ce temps le reste est pas
une nation qui était qui était bien
haïti mais tu vis l'église reste
problématique mais le point tarmed de
dire que c'est un lieu
2 comme conversation est ce que tu
pouvais un oui mais c'est parce que tu
avais une personne oui mais tu avais
aussi une personne qui parlait de
principes et de valeurs anti je pense
pas qu'ils aient un ego qui ressuscitait
pour ouvrir dès demain ce serait très
étonnant je pense pas qu'ils aient
changé loin en vain mot mais je pense
qu'il faut comprendre faut faire la
différence entre les métaphores
l'histoire la manière romancée
d'expliquer les choses puis de prendre
les messages mettons de jésus qui dit
aimez vous les uns les autres
le problème est normal je vois un
problème avec des évêques qui touchent à
des tigres mais pour moi le message
réalisation complète qui sut croyances
nos investisseurs pitié mais bon les dix
commandements tu lis ça ça bien dans
leur tête ils vont pas trompé sa femme
sopo dessus et on voisin tu vois pas
volé je pense que c'est un peu la base
d'une société et qui comprend qui est en
santé puis après ce bain tout ce que les
hommes en ont fait c'est dégueulasse tu
comprends mais le principe de base c'est
important puis juste faire une
parenthèse sur ce que tu dis par rapport
au confessionnal moi je pense que david
criton propre enfer ton propre paradis
si tu commets je dis n'importe quoi puis
je veux pas excuser le geste d'une
personne qui est ivre au volant qui fait
un accident avec une autre personne
tout le monde s'en sort heureusement
cette personne ne vit déjà l'enfant vit
l'enfer pour faire de quoi du genre faut
que souffrant nestea parce que sinon
c'était une personne normale consciente
qu'ils avaient des bonnes intentions du
froid jamais sûr il ya prévient la
justice et compagnie qui qui qui est
qu'ils méritent is on n'a besoin que
cette personne soit puni c'est sûr et
certain
mais il ya déjà un enfer comme émotif
qui vit que par sept personnages que je
pense qu'il faut pas l'oublier non
définitivement mais en fait je renchéris
ressources qui étudient dans leur
communication intense la communication
de s'asseoir peeters
quand tu fais ce je me sens de cette
façon le prix comment qu'on peut faire
pour continuer dans l'ensemble
quant à pornichet relations amoureuses
relations amicales me lie à mon avis
familiale wever peut dire que ça qu'on
fait pour les deux avancer ensemble
puissent à ccc c'est l'intelligence
émotionnelle pcc beaucoup plus important
qu'on le pense pas je pense que de plus
en plus on le découvre en tant que
société que tu disais dix ans quand sa
part les anxiétés
rex a fait pas longtemps qu'on parle
d'anxiété puis est-ce que l'anxiété
c'est quelque chose qui nous vaut
peut-être lent que c'était quelque chose
qui a plus maintenant à cause du rejet
de la société du rythme de la vie mais
je pense que c'est quelque chose de
nouveau
ben non mais moi je pense à ce pic
angers quand j'avais commencé à
m'intéresser aux six premières crises
comme 18h a toujours mentionné dans une
boutique de tatous permanent je pensais
que j'allais crever john dohmen et après
ça ben t'as pas d'avoir ce feeling
affective la peur d'avoir peur l'anxiété
ça va servir que ce qu'il neige du
manager du camp soir matthew rées et là
j'avais été écoute j'ai agité j'avais 24
ans environ quand j'ai été chercher mon
premier livre fait que six ans entre les
deux j'étais arrivé au nombre et sur
saint denis puis il y avait trois livres
dans la section développement personnel
ou oliver puis aujourd'hui tu vas chez
renaud bray c'est la catégorie qui
vendent le plus
après l'ailier de cuisine développement
la sonnette anxiété angoisse
il ya plein plein plein d'affaires puis
quand tu parles de la communication dire
à quelqu'un quand tu fais ça je me sens
comme ça sa voie double sens il faut que
la personne soit 4 de l'exprimer
correctement il faut aussi que deux la
personne qui le reçoit le reçoivent pas
comme une attaque
si par exemple on a un conflit toit puis
moi je t'ai dit ph quand tu mets ton
juste me quand invite des amis à maison
pitt oublie que je suis pendant mes
études ça me gausse vraiment beaucoup
mais tout pourrait faire arnaquer
j'avais dit m pas mes amis comme non non
non non non c'est pas ce que je te dis
je te dis qu'elle me ton ta liberté à
wright ou la mienne commence jan aps la
mouche dans une période d'étude pas
comment on peut couper puis mnc la base
de tous les conflits sur la terre pense
pense aux personnes trans en ce moment
pensons aux personnes de race noire et
disent on est victime de discrimination
objet véritable marasme ou d'ananas
c'est pour ça qu'on dit bord est ce
qu'on dit c'est qui encore des personnes
à cause qu'ils ont la peau noire qui
subissent des inégalités et des
injustices
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire parce qu'ils
sont pas là pour les fans je dis à
personne qui cache une sur le fait
qu'ils aient des inégalités puis de
l'injustice à cause des couleurs d'une
peau c'est pas vrai tu comprends wild et
des personnes dans les médias qui en
parliez des activistes mais leur but
c'est pas 200 millions au lieu des
personnes avec des bonnes intentions qui
veulent aider à faire avancer des causes
puis des enjeux sociaux
si on prenait la peine d'enseigner à nos
enfants comment répondre à ce genre
d'affaires le puits comment s'exprimer
dans une situation où il aime pas à dire
non je pars je pense juste à la culture
du viol c'est la même chose il ya des
jeunes filles des filles des femmes
on apprend lequel la majorité des femmes
qu'on connaît calvaire qu'ils ont subis
des pas des agressions mais des moments
où il n'était pas à l'aise sexuellement
avec des partenaires puis même en public
avec des hommes qui les regardaient de
travers
puis tu puisses ces personnes 9 voice un
concert qui est ce titre un paquet de
gens qui ont subi les vierges offensées
atteint 2 secondes
on dit pas que c'est un épais parce que
tu es un homme blanc de 40 ans péter
privilégie ce qu'on dit c'est que tu as
plus de chances qu'un paquet de monde
fait prendre deux secondes parce que ça
veut pas dire non plus que t'as pas de
problème dans vip que t'as pas besoin
d'être correct qui va gooden toute ta
vie ça veut juste dire qu'il ya déjà il
ya un gros problème en ce moment c'est
grandissant ce problème le flacon on
peut l'écouter tu peux écouter un autre
problème si tu peux choisir ce que tu
fais mais comme de bâcher du monde qui
volent 55 c'est d'aller à l'encontre du
développement d'intelligence émotive
puis quand ces foules important qu'on
apprenne cela nos jeunes je pense plus
que le théorème de pythagore
mais faisons dont les deux c'est
possible de faire les deux
combret laissé de côté le bouclier
canadien j'avais le chantre le théorème
de pythagore puis le bouclier canadien
je laisserais ali le théorème de
pythagore possiblement sais tu combien
de fois j'ai calculé la surface d'un
triangle dans ma vie mais combien de
prêcher l'hypoténuse attristé quoi déjà
c'était au magot le ciné sinus tangente
il est avait une équation à faire pour
trouver l'autre ligne une des trois
lignes en tout cas c'est en avait deux
pilotes avaient les plus dépendants du
triangle fans mais c'est quand même tu
sais quand même une tradition même qui
nous vient des grecs en 6 quand même
incroyable ces seuils techniques--
découvert ce et comme accueille une
formule pour trouver ce qu'il veut c'est
comme c'est comme un savoir pilotis qui
qui se transmet maintenant travers les
millénaires mois ci ce qui
m'impressionne le plus c'est pitié je
pense que c'est encore
ces sites étaient allés au mois d'avril
science tout et aurait eu besoin d'être
sur le type c c'est quasiment plus
télématin au secondaire aux primaires je
pense qu'elle soit plus une gymnastique
mentale s émousser inite et des
exercices des pro shop de serre voter
oui absolument sens sauf que
l'intelligence pour moi c'est un spectre
d'un cent soit de négligence matériel
intelligence émotive tu peux être plus
forts en maths plus fort en langue du
petit fort pour déceler comment une
personne c'est sans défaire une
situation de crise c'est je pense que ce
qu'on manque c'est de capitaliser sur
les talents et les qualités site 7000
défaut puis une qualité capitalise sur
ta qualité les défauts vont disparaître
de même puis les autres qualités vont
arriver à cheval mon golf dans camille
c'est vraiment important de capitaliser
sur des qualités des talents six mois à
l'école est un bon orateur fait qu'en
français puis dans les eaux rouges torch
est tout pigé aider mes amis dit combien
je leur disais même où une enfant je
fais ce même où seulement bieber fait
que je devenais avec tarder en même
temps mais je pense qu'on sait pas ce
qu'on n'a pas le temps si la prendre
dans une classe le tout pas longtemps ce
brassard avec chaque individu quelle est
ta force c'est comme c'est difficile de
force avec les ressources qu'on a fait
que je sais pas si c'est de chialer sur
le système ou juste de dire une chose de
très bons de base et comment on peut
l'adapter mieux encore je dis tantôt aux
extrémités puis sortir un peu de la
moyenne
je pense que le la difficulté c'est que
plus le temps avance dans l'histoire
plus le monde change rapidement
s'il n'y a pas grande différence entre
l'an 1000 plants 1206 we did d'armagnac
les gens vivent que la technologie
existe et fonctionne ce mets en 2000
puis 2019 une hausse si des différends
maxi techniquement moudjar de la maire
de lens est sage que l'an 1700
il évolue et un seul jusqu'à la
renaissance man le plus savant
technologie évolue rapidement
plus ça change nos comportements en tant
qu'humain nos relations
interpersonnelles factice qui était vrai
vous êtes dans les années 60 sur comment
c'était quoi un bon modifications c'est
vraiment vraiment appris aujourd'hui
c'est le fameux livre sur commettre une
bonne femme au foyer mais oui mon cas
non ça suffisait il lisait des exemples
des passages classe mais c'est mon job
vous serez prêtre lorsqu'il arrivera pas
comment non ça c'est fou mais c'est
probablement que le fait que à l'époque
si si on a moins de l'agenda prenez-le
avec les eaux du goyen thé avec la
technologie de se passe plus on a le
plus virtuellement mais c'est vraiment
le style il ne s'est pas à l'esprit de
famille les ligatures inglés tilt je
parle à mon voisin puis 10e j'ai
l'impression que ce contact le vraiment
du moins humain sans les termes et de
technologie est en diminution
supplémentaire qui est en diminution
mais je trouve qu'il est en augmentation
en termes de qualité parce que quand je
marque pour ma part quand j'en ai un je
saisis le moment là si georges roques
dans la vie à pleines dents et la
gestion était une anomalie dans la façon
avec laquelle on vit où là il ya des
gars qui travaillent chez nous à ce
moment qu'ils font et rénove des trucs
puis je mouche fasciné par tout dans la
vie je suis vraiment gaussin le cas est
que de nouveaux qui arrivent le faux
j'arrête je comprenne que ce soit de
ligue 1 je vais justement je pense du
côté du truck le jeudi c'est chez lui
parce que moi quand je croise quelqu'un
je le salue je demande ma vie que je ne
connaissais pas je le salue comme des
fois j'ai oublié qu'il ya certaines
personnes qui peuvent me connaître c'est
wild pour résoudre parce qu'ils ont
commis il marque une métaphore on sent
bien que si tu sais vraiment adroit au
tir j'ai pourtant connu xul puis le
gauche tellement new york en tant que
gérant contact avec vous pour faire
comme je l'avais pas vu juste quand je
vais ça lui plaît chez régis baudrigues
caisses du fait en occident ont fait de
revêtement petite jackie page évidente
entre tavannes longue affaire pour
couper comme du revêtement j'ai dit
c'est quoi attirer comme un truc de
presse publique
expliquer ton affable et ce matin encore
je croise un autre groupe easybike kong
fidler événements comme je sais que nous
auto conduite vous qu'on leur fasse
maintenant j'ai dit vous êtes un groupe
que je pose des questions sur ce qui
fait ça m'intéresse tu comprends avec
j'ai un échange et qu'un humain je veux
pas savoir c'est en 1111 de plus mais
comme on est content de se parler il ya
précises comme un genre de frissons de
mahler espèces comme un j'ai parlé un
humain comme et il était tombé gentille
fille comme mais oui mais un but qui
mettait des piaules autrefois dans le
sol pour un une véranda y sérieux je les
regardais pendant une demi heure je
regardais comment qui faisait son enfant
j'étais conquis le marteau le fait le
laser la machine à la fin j'ai posé des
questions jeu comme je faisais un
entrevue j'étais comme le la machine
s'ils arrivent de la fair play était
capable et ch'ti qui était passionné et
puis quand même si c'est un sport que ça
prend tu vois le gars y était content
parce que ça n'arrive pas tous les jours
c'était quand je pense vraiment pas que
ça arrive tous les jours je pense que
cette année c'est arrivé de se faire
questionner sur les us et coutumes et
ils dorment intérêts imaginons fait tout
et oui mais ça c'est il faudrait faire
tu imagines matonge par juste pour
l'anxiété puis l'angoissé imagine le
matin ou le montrer comme endroit était
angoissé mais ne sait vraiment en poche
je comprends ce que tu vis
surtout qu'on en parle imagine si ça
c'est la réaction globale à l'anxiété
puis l'angoissé à quel point l angoisse
a disparu à son équipe pour ça c'est sûr
et certain
si tu sais que tu as des ressources puis
du petit côté de quelque chose mais
comme tu dis c'est vrai que ça doit être
assez qui est un peu rude peut-être
limiter sa banane mais c'est aux numéros
et ses hôtes maison moi je n'ai pas
croire qu'ils étaient dans un bus tu
parles pas que la personne qui chauffe
mots quand j'irai dans un taxi ou un
robot wall-e veux et je vois que la
personne vient pas du même coup elle a
pas d origine du même pays que mois
après en question que je pose si des
outils vie comme je suis pas contre eux
mais les gens disent je suis né à
montréal jusqu'au match par areva je
trouve ça drôle mais je voudrais comme
je le vois que tu es descendance
africaine ou haïtienne comme raconte moi
ça parce que je sais pas plus
aujourd'hui à des gens qui disent que
c'est raciste encore le racisme si je
pose pas de questions comment tu veux
qu'on élimine la barrière en tenue de ce
congrès francis pose pas de questions
permanent famille et non pas du tout
évident ce sera six dépôts québécois
opté pour montréal ltée pas quoi que ce
soit je suis arrivé un des teasers
une picone ces écoutes c'est incroyable
mathieu manet qui venait de la réussite
mais cris qui était parti si juste un
peu après l'histoire de tchernobyl parce
qu'ils avaient peur des radiations pitot
qui lui était il y avait un très bon
emploi là bas ils sont diplômés
n'étaient pas reconnus ici mais qui
avait trouvé un peu de bonheur d'un truc
du taxi parce qu'avec son propre record
qui rencontrait du monde puis il me
raconter un peu c'était quoi la culture
la bo puis quand ça fonctionne bien quel
point était content d'être dans une
société libérale quand même ici on est
quand même assez avancées au niveau
communautaire puis voyez le filet social
puis les itinérants qui l'est les
policiers venaient porter des manteaux
épisode pitre c'est extraordinaire puis
me racontais ma ville comme je l'avais
jamais vu perspectives à lui c'est ça
qui contribuent à payer des taxes ils
paient de l'impôt il travaillait des
gens il ya un bon quart de ce mois je
pensais tout ce que ça brille en clair
ces classes c'est d'avoir des
discussions qui qui s'éloigne de ton de
ton quotidien mais ton cercle ton cercle
fermé ou ta chambre des coopératives moi
c'était pour avoir pour avoir des
perspectives qui sont différentes c'est
vraiment je crois c'est sur la base la
communication c'est vraiment c'est c'est
de ça qu'on a perdu j'ai l'impression
qu'on qu'on n'utilise pas assez parce
qu'on a la capacité de communiquer c'est
ce qui fait d'eux des humains qui se
différencie le plus des animaux c'est de
se communiquer des émotions des idées
précises des des concepts flous quand et
comment les concepts abstraits on est
capable de s'en parler
et là on se parle on se parle de la même
chose on se parle la même chose tout le
temps ouais moi je pense que c'est parce
que je pensais impossible quand
l'intérieur de 10 minutes si tu pose les
bonnes questions à n'importe qui qui
deviennent pas que ce soit plus
favorable a développé une amitié que
cette personne peu importe la personne
c'est l'anti minutes les bonnes
questions
tu comprend d'où la personne des
chaussures et certains je te pardonne et
meurtrier en série ou dans nos
fondamentaux
je parle en général pas noir qui dans la
rue quelqu'un qui fait un truc de ouf je
me soignais qu'un grand choc puis on a
la même place et que nos filles s'il
apprend pauline pis c'était un peu de ma
faute honnêtement puis j'étais vraiment
vraiment fort j'ai bien évidemment ma
fille tori remarqué puis son enfant non
plus mais comme quand on était dans lieu
après acheter comme oh my god mais c'est
tellement ridicule j'allais le voir j'ai
serré la main j'ai dit je veux je te dis
que je m'excuse j'ai vraiment été épais
je suis désolé tu mérites passagers dit
si on fait passe en ce moment le tout tu
t'en vas chez vous des fourches et je
m'en vais chez nous fâcher tu te
souviens que telle personne a fait
quelques aveux stick le monde une gaffe
tu sais tu que tu contribues à la grogne
populaire de tout le monde s'est abstenu
parce que isco punch out
puis j'ai fait comme moi je vais briser
sadr est le ca a été ainsi de travail
pour l'ego mais comme j'avais envie que
c'est que le passé un bon moment avec
son enfant parce que moi aussi j'avais
la même affaire que je me dis si moi
j'ai envie d'être
il ya probablement envie de ce fait je
trouve ça important surtout d'aller vers
des gens qui nous intéresse peau des
hommes et des gens qui font des affaires
c'est maintenant moi qui passion donc je
n'ai jamais écouté je sais que tu as
participé mais j'ai zéro jugement par
rapport à ce jeu c'est qu'il y en a qui
disent ce qu'il faut pas il faut pas que
tu oublie qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
regardent ce pour un paquet de raisons
différentes mouches comme tu m'invites a
amené josé faire quoi et je vais amener
qui s'avère d'autant plus intéressant
parce que l'univers dans lequel tu
gravité pendant un certain moment
ces supports loin de moi je connais
parce que je pense que c'est une
gymnastique un peu comment on parle des
mathématiques je pense qu'il faut faire
faire cette gymnastique le à nos jeunes
n'y aller en dehors de leur zone de
confort puis en dehors des chambres
d'écho aussi si je pense qu'il va
permettre d'anéantir des choses comme le
racisme dite et a fortement infléchi si
on se donne la liberté d'être fort chez
pizza fois puis peu importe c'est quoi
la liberté d'expression c'est hyper
important
et après ce bon sens on s'écoute puis on
a des ducation d'intelligence émotive
qui nous sert à recevoir cette
information aussi tu t'en doutes être
quelque chose que j'ai aimé quand il
parlait de l'émission 8/10 et on sait la
madame au début le ticket
qui les problèmes de santé mentale ont
honte et ondiste une crise de folles
mais c'est pas une crise de folles qui
justement tu sais moi j'ai déjà mais ne
cache t plus jeunes mais ton de ces
personnes est une crise de foi ou à la
vérité en réel le prophète métier la
réalité c'est que ça existe pas tous
dans le fond des crises de folles ou des
crises de wever c'est des gens des
problèmes c'est des gens avec des
problèmes de santé mentale ou qui ont eu
des certaines blessures oui certaines
choses dans la vie que fait que ceux qui
en sont à leur type y compris c'est en
pratique tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est
aider ces gens lieu où vous dire c'est
pas mon combat mais sans les juger le
serment d y aussi des décidé de pas
s'entourer de personnes qui nous amène
du négatif oui mais d'en rajouter en dix
ans une crise de folie qui s'agitent
c'est que ça soit même en écoutant
occupation double envoie les routes
espace il de juger dans sept sites
d'émission le cfai très exactement pour
ça moi je trouve ça fait appel à un côté
un peu ville de l'être humain et et
voyeur estimé anne est d'écraser le mans
nantes en daim rouge pas de même puis
nanana mais comme si on voit ces
personnes à qui on arrête de penser au
jeu comme par exemple se voir un
itinérant qui se met à crier dans rude
et ailleurs l'institut me dérange ou
erreurs je suis dérangé au plus se dit
il a besoin d'être bien visiblement qui
a besoin d'être segaud loyers sur
mont-royal saint denis puis ils crient
au soleil de fermer sa gueule comme
c'est sûr qu'ils aient pas bien à l'eau
c'est vraiment pas compliqué du comprend
merci review cela mais on ne dit pas que
lui il dérange
il dérange la société honnêtement qui
dérange ou une dérange pauvreté y est en
crise contre les chalets il ya le droit
techniquement il yal droite comprend
autant que je dois marcher trop top ça
c'est juste que si c'est bien plus
néfaste pour lui ce qui est en train
d'arriver que pour moi par exemple on
parle des personnes schizophrènes les
personnes schizophrènes dont 75% plus de
chances d'être victimes d'actes de
violence que d'en faire parce que la
famille en abuse où on leur extorquent
de l'argent ou parce que ces gens là ont
pas toujours une pleine conscience ou
une capacité de conscience qui est la
même que la nôtre
il faut agir avec les chiffres qu'on
appelait statistiques justement pauvres
se dire y'a pas de crise de fou de
crises a froissé des gens qui sont en
dit c'est de la détresse et un besoin
d'ambition reconnaissent comme comme ce
que c'est parce qu'il ya énormément de
ressources d'être qu'on connaît pas je
veux dire à montréal parce que c'est
celle que je connais mais en régions
aussi il ya des gens qui travaillent à
ceux qui se mettront jamais riche avec
ce mai comme jour après jour sont dans
rue avec les itinérants avec les
personnes en santé mentale
ils sont sont pas justes d'enrhumer dans
des centres de soins dans des maisons où
ces gens le sont sont prises en charge
comme ça comme ça pour moi ce livre est
érotique comprend puis si on avait
autant d'empathie qu'on en eau pour me
ton la petite fille qui est décédée à
granby
mais on fera un maudit bon plus du tout
j'ai l'impression que c'est que on
s'était vu la première fois tous signé
des livres renaud bray soutient denis
puis quand je rentrais tu m'avais dit
que je pense que je me suis me trompe
dans l'histoire mais qui m'a dit que sur
un nombre et leur ton grand père qui
était en avance sur un nombre et leur a
tous les jours ouais y très probablement
geignant c'est quoi la relation que tu
avais avec ton grand-père ou cocteau ou
que je sais pas mais très probablement
que d'avoir cette percée qui sert cette
pardon perspective le devoir de savoir
que quelqu'un proche de toi vécu ce
quelqu'un en tondant ta famille a vécu
sur promet que toi tu vois pas les
itinérants de la même façon du mot poli
de tous ces petits et cette perspective
là qui est différente de la société en
général qui juste années quand il ya
quelqu'un qui kate à apporter juste
détourner le regard pour garder ben
c'est sûr que oui parce que encore une
fois ma copine a travaillé tout l'hiver
avec des personnes en situation
d'itinérance
puis je me suis amusé des chiffres le
titre l on la partage cet avis est le
matin tout l'hiver les pieds dans l'eau
au fret
puis avant avec des policiers de ce
travail avec avec les mairies qui est
une une cellule qui a été créée par la
police de montréal pour intervenir
auprès des personnes en situation
d'itinérance puis j'ai toujours lever
mon chapeau à cette initiative là parce
que pour ouvrir sa soeur du monde s'est
passé pas de donner des tickets aux
itinérants ou sa femme a même c'est de
vraiment prendre en charge ces personnes
là à tous les niveaux puis apprécier des
années par un niveau supérieur de prise
en charge à partir du moment où sont
capables de se sortir de situations
comme se dit quand je vois des gars de
mon âge qui kate gestique sont aptes au
travail le cycle pourrait travailler à
la construction puisque vitaux deux
choix d'yves allons travailler et steed
bon à rien ou tu dis comment ça se fait
qu'avec tout ce que tu t'es pas capable
d'aller travailler
il ya quelque chose ici qui fonctionne
pas autre chose aussi qui fonctionne pas
il faut qu'on le règle puis moi ça me
fait plaisir que les impôts qu'on paye
en gang ça aide ce jeune homme là où
cette jeune femme le à se sortir d'une
situation dont personne que personne
souhaite à la base parce qu'il y en a il
y en a qui le disent je veux mourir dans
la rue il y en a qui veulent rester dans
la rue son bain le ceo c'est leur
manière de ne pas se conformer puis je
peux comprendre ça parce que j'ai déjà
une pas envie de me conformer
je suis pas allé jusque là mais je peux
comprendre et apprécier ces personnels
demandent rien à part un peu de sou de
monsieur madame pis je dis à personne
qui les force à donner de l'argent en
fait tu peux pas blâmer quelqu'un qui
est et s'il fait semblant d'avoir
appauvri un triple jeu de poker tout ce
monde là je me sens désolé rêveur mais
comme au juste comme on est le jugement
facile ça se passe rapidement on est
bombardé
dans les médias de gens qui savent tout
juste s'ils ont des opinions sur tout
moche connaisseur moi je connais si mais
comme on prend jamais le temps de voir
les choses pour ce qu'ils sont ou les
personnes en situation d'itinérance le
ou mettons les goûts j'ai toujours
trouvé ça drôle les bs qui partent en
voyage avec mes textes et frost aval
c'est pas vraiment arrivé puis la fraude
sociale
c'est une infime partie de la fraude
fiscale
curieux pourtant crise on passe de la
dbs qui partent en voyage avec mes
textes
mais on parle pas de chez pas quelle
personne qui est multimillionnaire qui
lui se paye un jet sur le bras des
contribuables parce qu'elle a besoin
d'aller le pilote qui contribuent à la
pollution possible sa saucisse kristen
entrepreneuriat travail est parti puis
moi j'ai toujours trouvé ça drôle parce
que quand on parle du succès trois fois
par jour
je me sentais mal déjà nommé du travail
fort doute mon père a travaillé toute sa
fucking vie dans un garage 45 heures par
semaine il lui travaillé fort mais je
travaille pas fort encore une fois je
fais des photos de pogo toute la journée
dit oui j'en fais beaucoup oui on
travaille mais je travaille pas plus
fort c'est pas parce que j'ai ce succès
là que j'ai travaillé plus fort qu'un
enseignant qui fait 35 40 45 1000 par
année et qui comprend c'est ça il n'y a
pas de lien ici tout se sait mélanger
puis on n'en parle pas souvent et c'est
ce que je sois on parle de santé mentale
depuis tantôt que tu disais que c'était
pas mon sens de travailler là dessus et
on parlait de thérapie on parle m6 quoi
concrètement le fonds qui est allé
chercher comment j'ai commencé avec un
livre qui s'appelait la peur d'avoir
peur qui a été écrit écrit par une
psychologue québécoises dont le nom
m'échappe
ça m'a appris le processus biologiques
et les processus techniques de la crise
de panique
enfin une histoire courte dans ton
cerveau ou ce qu'on appelle l'amygdale
ahmed a réagi à des stimuli des des
symboles de choses comme ça
et dans le fond une réaction primal qui
est le fun
or flight succombent à 17,7 amygdales là
des fois fait défaut et dans le fond
qu'en a fait défaut c'est quand vous
êtes à votre rigueur ton cerveau avoir
peur ou à vouloir fuir dans des
situations qui sont tout à fait normal
par exemple une soirée entre amis
parler devant le public monte des
escaliers le vertige ce genre d'affaires
le j'ai compris comment ça fonctionne
dans mon corps à partir de schémas ok
voici ce qui se passe quand ça arrive
donc quand ça ça arrive peut essayer de
me raisonner à savoir des pas en train
de mourir
c'est ton cerveau qui na na nana na na
pour moi c'était pas assez suffisant
ensuite j'ai acheté un livre qui
s'appelle l'art du bonheur du dalaï lama
puis j'ai acheté aussi le bouddhisme
pour les nuls j'avais besoin de
spiritualité j'avais besoin de
comprendre pourquoi certaines personnes
croyaient en une force plus grande que
même m j'ai lu là dessus dans les
principes du bouddhisme mieux la route
du dharma qu'on appelle qui explique que
dans la vie tu es sur une roupie tu
avances mais si tu arrêtes d'avancé tu
tombes et je trouve ça intéressant parce
que c'est ça la vie en réalité c'est que
si tu avances pas sûr que c'est comme un
tapis roulant qui bouge toujours le
temps avance constamment facile dois
apparaître
le temps continue à avancer fait
techniquement circulent encore se dit
qu'il faut toujours faire l'effort faut
toujours choisir de faire des affaires
et puis c'est là que j'ai commencé à
douter du fait que je voulais devenir
humoriste ou faire de la télé jeter
comme on dirait que j'ai beau me lever
le matin pour choisir ce c'est pas ce
qui m'allume du tout du tout ensuite
j'ai lu un livre qui s'appelle guérir de
david servan-schreiber il celui qui a
créé si je me si ma mémoire est bonne la
faculté de neurologie de l'université
d'atlanta en georgie
je me suis que des diagnosticiens
neurologue c'est un monsieur qui était
diagnostiquée du cancer du cerveau à une
certaine époque il y avait donné deux
mois à vivre avait que 15 ans là dessus
maliki a fait des recherches sur les
manière naturelle du corps de se
départir du stress
le livre guérir c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que ça dit guérir et
calmer les symptômes de l'anxiété du
stress et de la dépression sans
médicaments
moi je trouvais ça vraiment intéressant
je ne dis pas par contre que tu peut
guérir la dépression sans médicaments
certaines personnes en ont besoin il est
d'une grande aide et d'une grande
pertinence aussi d'en avoir fait que je
pense que c'est du cas par cas mais pour
moi ce livre leur faisait vraiment la
faire au moment où j'allais lui il
parlait de comment freiner ce qu'on
appelle le système parasympathique
d'enfants qui est un système nerveux
avec des exercices de respiration c'est
des choses qui m'ont qui m'ont sauvé des
grandes crises de panique
concrètement ensuite j'ai consulté une
psychologue j'ai consulté un
psychanalyste puis en ci dessous je suis
allé vers une autre forme de thérapie
qui s'appelle la pénurie qui veut dire
pastry arditi intégration qui a été
inventé par une dame qui s'appelle
ingeborg bosch bonomo qui allemande qui
est une docteure en psychologie puis et
partait de quelques théories de freud
plus des exercices clinique de certains
autres docteurs aussi en psychologie et
à ses rangs du conte dans le fond que la
majorité de nos réponses émotive à des
situations normales venait de blessures
d'enfance puis le livre s'appelle
illusion je le recommande à tout le
monde mais je pense que c'est important
de partir de la base
la peur d'avoir par le livre guérir puis
ensuite deux seuls les livres de
gameblog sur la paix harry partialité
intégration à qu'au fur et à mesure de
faire des thérapies de gossip de com de
com en scène connaître parce que quand
je travaille surtout à pitre rencontre
colog un psychanalyste un pilote des
rappeurs tu parle de toi tu t'entends tu
t'écoutes d'une personne te fait
miroiter des affaires que tu dis des
choses comme ça fait ça écoute il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas de secret il n'y a pas
de secret c'est des lectures de
l'apprentissage de soi même c'est
vraiment dur c'est vraiment vraiment
difficile il faut que la discipline de
le faire puis je suis fier parce que
c'est la seule chose ou presque dans ma
vie que j'ai eu la discipline de fer
comme il faut ça a été de me guérir de
sa ferme où je disais je vois pas il est
avec sa va disparaître de ma vie c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé mais je
pense que c'est passé pour pour plein de
personnes jouera berges pourrez vous
empêche pas s'il avait reçus joueurs
mondialistes et je m'en veux savoir
faire de la moto on s'entend tous je
voyais à parler d'art et jo il ya eu une
grosse dépression jours puis il ya eu
beaucoup de problèmes d'anxiété des
crises de panique puis en parle
ouvertement pareil comme moi mais il y
est d'accord avec moi le truc c'est pas
le yoga les joueurs puis bien manger le
truc c'est la thérapie c'est des choses
que tu peux que toi seul peut régler si
toi que la clé de ce il faut que tu
ailles chercher de l'aide de poche soit
pas juste totaux guérir je pense que le
yoga ce qui se passe c'est que titre
découvre les young gods comment faire
face au maine mais c'est fou le bon qui
s'impliquent rim se sent mieux
c'était un crime spirituel puis je me
sens mieux et juste je fais du sport
très puissant l'activité physique sont
allés courir mais non sans paix il fait
chaud l'activité physique on le sait
c'est la meilleure chose que tu peux
faire pour ton corps pour ton esprit
aussi une des meilleures choses partie
si ça c'est pas aux mines une force
surnaturelle s'est juste fait du pôle
scientifique et celio gaye annexé la
course est important mais ça pour moi
c'est pas une manière de guérir c'est
juste une gêne davis ben je crois je
crois que c'est dans ce que le pic est
là
les verts pitou après le hit in living
je pense que c'est un peu une porte
d'entrée vers la découverte de soi ben
oui terne mais dont les gens commencent
à faire du rugby qui font un outil je me
sens bien peu importe la raison pour
laquelle ils font puis faire après si tu
commences à t'intéresser tiens qu'est ce
que tu peux manger qu'est ce que tu peux
mettre dans ton corps qui va être mieux
que la pression du camp s'est intéressé
à des trucs plus spirituelle comme des
délits justement de ces offert des
livres de connaissances émotionnel c'est
pour commencer à développer ce je pense
vraiment que seul le mouvement autour du
ring c'est vraiment une porte d'entrée
vers ce pays
les questionnements et c'est toujours
bon c'est toujours bon de se questionner
de chercher de trouver des nouvelles
affaires pour se sentir mieux dans son
corps dans son esprit wever après ce il
faut juste développer une petite esprit
critique pour déterminer le bon du
mauvais parce que tu m'aimes dans les
vêtements personnels ti mousse chimique
sujet des fois par rapport à ça parce
qu'il y en a qui en font une business ou
ce qu'ils vendent des livres très jeune
au niveau belge à l'antenne par stefanie
powers autre que les contextuel tony
brown se remplit des stades de 4000
personnes qui payent 4000 pièces par
bill pourrait être le cas et puis le
gosse qui d'ici est capable ouais et en
gros le si pas mal ça je te dis il parle
pas de retour sur investissement est pas
de quel portefeuille ont bien performé
dans les 50 dernières années les indices
de la bourse comme ça fonctionne d
insight sur comment être avec un cash
flow
il fait juste dix ans je sais que tu es
capable dude vos emails regarde moi
j'étais cas pas commencer à t'entraîner
moujalli fait chèque ça y est c'est sûr
je sais que d'un autre côté il faut pas
juger l'aide que les gens vont chercher
tu me donnes moi oprah winfrey je ne me
sens pas touchés par cette personne mais
j'essaie khaled bon nombre de gens
vivaient chez oprah winfrey est ce que
c'est une personne qui fait des choses
extraordinaires pour des pour des gens
qui ont besoin d aide
c'est comme ça
contribuer au bien-être elle aussi à sa
manière pour d'autres types de gens il
faut comprendre envie que c'est pas tout
le monde qui paraît comme toi puisque tu
peux pas juste vos recettes de ton point
de vue déjà quand un vol tony brown fine
mais tu regardes l'essentiel du contenu
je trouve ça un peu je sais pas si je
n'ai jamais fait mais je sais pas si je
perds et 4000 pièces vont aller loin
exact et puis un versement dans la santé
t c'est parfait de rechercher des mers
façon très précise de l'alimentation
bougies de se mêler quantité vente des
kits d d-tox puis des affaires qui
marchent moyens type est le gros prix
pour ce et le rapport une bonne
intention
je pense que je parle le consommateur
lui tout ce qu'il veut c'est sentir
mieux bien sûr ils essaient d affaires
sauf qu'il ya nexon avoir tifa qui se
dit d'accord c'est l'esprit qui sait
qu'après sept des semaines le bon du
mauvais là dedans alex va partir à oued
déjà c'était vraiment ne parle pas
vraiment content pour lui survient la
main mais quand vous m'avez invité
et oui certains s merci beaucoup merci à
vous et bonne après-midi légaux
[Musique]